wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn what Warren Buffett gets wrong
about today's market how to shatter the
chains of poverty the number one wealth
hack if you're starting from zero and
the top strategies to pay less taxes get
ready to follow the blueprint to
generate substantial wealth
enjoy hello welcome back for episode 10
of wealth breakthroughs I'm Patrick
gentempo today we're going to start with
Andy Snyder from madwood press who's
going to say what so many others are
afraid to say Andy's going to show you
what Warren Buffett gets wrong about
today's markets obviously viously
buffets an inspiration to anyone seeking
New Wealth but Andy says he's fallen
behind for a shocking reason here's Andy
with
[Music]
more Andy I really been looking forward
to this conversation so thanks for
taking the time to sit with us
absolutely thank you well you have a
very interesting story so uh why don't
you tell us about your background and
what got you into doing what you're
doing sure so my background I think it's
pretty unique and varied um my high
school career was was not much of a
career I think if my high school
guidance counselor is watching this I
win the
bet she loses um but you know I never
thought I'd be in the the wealth world
right so I had a pretty lousy High
School career um took some time off
spent two years building houses I think
it was the the best education I ever got
was getting out there you know skipping
College taking that break and going out
and just seeing the the real world um
building houses learning how the
business World works you know if
something breaks in my house now I can
fix it you know I had to know how to do
that and that's really important um so
did that for two years decided I want to
be an engineer follow my dad's footsteps
go into the engineering World um did a
semester in college uh very quickly
realized math probably wasn't my
favorite thing I did really well in it
just wasn't my favorite thing to do um I
had an English class the English
professor said you need to do this you
need to be a writer mhm so I I actually
changed schools um decided to go for
English did four years of that then uh
graduated uh College realized there's
nothing for a English major to do so I
went into the financial world I was
always uh really intrigued by that had a
good friend that was uh U always picking
stocks I was I was picking stocks my own
uh became a financial adviser realized
quickly that nobody wants Financial
advice from a 20 22-year- old so I I put
my skills together was uh you know use
an English degree to write about finance
and that's how I got into this career
how long you been doing that now uh 15
years or so yeah so uh so basically
interesting you didn't listen to your
high school guidance counselor but you
did listen to your College English
teacher that's right yeah I learned my
lesson you got to pick and choose who
you listen to well and you know as much
as that's an entertaining statement it's
true right picking and choosing who you
listen to because you know you're in the
business of getting people to listen to
you through your Communications so uh so
did you think that you could really make
a go at just writing about uh financial
information uh or was it did you think
it had a low probability succeeding um I
think it all depends on what you put
into it you know writing in general is
is really tough so go going through
college you know journalism making money
in the newspaper world really hard
everybody says you can't do that and I'm
really I'm not in this to make money I
think that's why I did make money um giv
expand on that what do why do you think
that's why you did make money because
you're unattached or you're just doing
it for the passion of the work I think
the The Passion of the work shows
through and so when you have a good
product people come for it when you're
trying to force a product onto the
market then you're going to have have
bigger issues yeah that makes sense so
uh with the writing that you do um how
much of the success of what you're doing
because I could speak especially for my
partner Jeff Hayes he is a huge fan of
men were digest and and uh you know he's
always forwarding things to me that I'm
reading I'm saying wow this is so well
written very compelling uh and the
actual subject matter content is
important so when you look at this how
much is uh style of writing you as far
as saying hey the end product and its
value to the the reader how much of that
is the quality of the writing if you
will and how much of that is the actual
subject content in and of itself sure
I'd say it's 80% style because you can
have the best ideas the the best
research but if nobody reads it nobody's
going to read it um if they don't care
they're not going to read it so you know
um I always joke that I write on a third
grade level I take that really seriously
make it so everybody can understand it
and wants to read it and that's I mean
to me that's really important if if they
don't enjoy reading it they're not going
to read it how do you decide what to
write about uh whatever uh I read a lot
I try to read a new book you know try to
dig into a new book every week uh most
of the time it's just whatever's on my
mind um and and that's the key to you
know just always have a a curious mind
I've always said that I'm dangerously
curious my wife would would certainly
say I'm dangerously curious and and that
Curiosity propels me into new subjects
you know all the time where is that
Curiosity LED you uh you know any any uh
wild destinations or interesting places
sure um probably the the the most
dangerous place that's ever led me was
the Wilds of Alaska how long ago was
that that was about 14 years ago ago 12
14 years ago um so I was doing this job
I was working from home one day so you
should never work from home and I got a
little bored and so I have my captain's
license big passion of mine is fishing
um so I went online and and decided
wonder what happens if I appli a couple
lodges I think I applied at three or
four by the end of the day I had two job
offers and uh I said this one has good
internet I can still do what I'm doing
here up there so I went for it um day
one or day two I met my wife um ended up
spending two years there and and met
some of the greatest people I've ever
met some of the richest wealthiest
people and a lot of my my thought
process now on wealth evolved up there
you know so going into that was very
conventional fundamental analysis you
know what I was taught in in uh college
and then through grad school um you know
the the traditional fundamental analysis
that everybody talks about then I get up
there I'm I'm fishing with hedge fund
managers um John Malone the richest uh
or largest landowner in the country
movie Producers my claim to fame I was
on uh the producer of The Aviator his
Christmas card holding the big old fish
um and got to know these guys really
well and learned how they make money and
what they think about money and and how
for many of them money made them
miserable they were coming up you know
getting away from California getting
away from the lower 48 coming up to the
middle of nowhere had all the money in
the world but it didn't matter up there
they just wanted to get away from it all
and get into nature and so that's when I
my my thoughts on wealth really started
to evolve can you maybe uh drill down a
little and tell us you know some of the
lessons you learned specifically maybe
from certain people that stand out in
your mind sure um you know talking with
uh I forget his name right now but he's
a a huge uh he's billionaire Walmart air
owns at the time owned the Denver
Nuggets and so we flew him up or he flew
up to be a part of this entertainment
investing group right and so he just
flew his private plane into catak can
flew a a float plane out there and he
lands at the dock shakes all of our hand
and says I hope this is worth it you
know so I look around and and you know
we're in the one of the most beautiful
places in in the country with great
people couldn't ask for a better thing
and all he really cared about was was
making more money and he just looked
miserable um and and you could just see
how that permeated a lot of people but I
got to see the the transformation of
folks so the way it worked up there is
folks would fly in you could only get
there by boat or float plane so once you
were there you know on the Rock we
called it you were there and they'd get
off the plane they'd introduce
themselves they'd say hey I'm I'm John
I'm an architect or I'm John uh Fred I'm
a lawyer they kind of identified by who
they were how much they money they made
um you didn't see the real person then
we'd spend three days five days up there
fishing uh exploring the Wilderness
really getting to understand how the
world Works around us and they change
and we'd see their they're happiness go
up and you know they started thinking
less about their bank account and how
they had to make more money how they can
enjoy what they had and and why they had
it does that lead you to certain um
conclusions about what how you might
define success or how you might Define
wealth sure wealth I I'll never deny
that wealth is important you know I just
got back from Nicaragua one of the the
the second poorest country only to Haiti
in the Western Hemisphere very poor but
very happy um but those folks aren't
free they're stuck you know in their
little posted St uh posted stamp plot of
land they can't get out if they wanted
to there's a lot of political tension a
lot of turmoil there so they they don't
have the money to to get something
better but they're still happy and I
think that's key where I see wealth
really being important what we write
about a lot in manward is that Liberty
side you look back through history the
wealthiest aren't always the happiest
but they're the freest when when
political tension Rises when whatever
happens family issues they have the
ability to move wherever they need to do
to go or do whatever they need to do um
you know they have the ability to quit a
jobs they don't like their boss they can
they can go on vacation here versus
there and you know that wealth really
pays off there so it's not the the Quest
for more money that should should drive
you it's that Quest For Freedom that I
always say should drive drive your idea
well circling back to the the
billionaire you're talking about saying
I hope this is worth it meeting you is
he going to you know somehow make bigger
deals or acquire more wealth when he
can't possibly spend the money he has in
multiple lifetimes uh did he have a
breakthrough did he have an epiphany uh
you what happened for him not while he
was there um I I certainly haven't seen
that but other people did based on that
so you know that that comment that you
know he said I hope this is worth it
everybody heard it uh we went for a hike
later that day I was with some younger
guys they heard it and these were guys
that were kind of following in in his
heels and they absolutely had an
epiphany um they were up there to to
discuss making money do business deals
in the entertainment world and they went
away knowing that those deals are
important but there's a whole lot more
to it they didn't want to end up like
that b iaire that that's kind of
miserable you know they want to be the
billionaire that doesn't have to go to
work every day so he became their
cautionary tale almost exactly yeah
don't be this this grumpy guy that
married into one of the the wealthiest
families built his own wealth and still
isn't happy that's not what any of us
are looking to do yeah it's interesting
too because when you're talking about
Nicaragua or or you know when people are
impoverished in in such a way um you
know when you're in survival mode uh you
know that's that's it's a really tough
circumstance to break out of and create
some level of Freedom do you find just
you know in your writings and and kind
of your experience that some people are
actually in that situation like in a
third world country such as that but
some people are here but they're like
that in their mind and they're kind of
stuck in that in their mind and they
can't break free for sure you know you
asked uh did I expect to make money
writing you know there's a conventional
logic that nobody gets successful
writing books or novels you know I wrote
my first book when I was still in in
college or grad school didn't make much
money that was the mindset but so many
people especially in America one of you
know the strongest countries in the
world have this mindset that they can't
do better on their own they depend on
the government you with the elections um
so many people are depending on on their
party to pick them up I said tell people
it doesn't matter you know it's what's
in here that's going to set you free or
or make you wealthy and if you have a
mindset that you're trapped and and your
family for whatever reason or because of
who you were who you are where you're
born that you're always going to be poor
yes you are always going to be poor but
you always see people that that break
out of that they they read books they
they set their goals they they are
determined to make money and they find a
way to do it and I think that's the the
absolute key it's it's it's not the
people in Nicaragua that were born
there's people there that are absolutely
getting rich and are are taking you know
advantage of their OPP entrepreneurial
opportunities and doing well and that
can be anywhere the streets of Baltimore
New York City wherever what are you
writing about most now like what's got
your attention what's got my attention
right now is is a lot of that taking
that conventional logic I look at
investing today as as a great Evolution
so you know I ended up going to to grad
school um very conventional background
there but everybody talks about modern
portfolio Theory I think it's a joke you
know modern portfolio theory is invented
1952 it's anything but modern these days
but yet it's the it's the investing
Canon it's what everybody talks about um
you know when when modern portfolio
Theory came out the internet wasn't
around news still traveled really slow
we didn't have 247 news Cycles so so
many folks are are still looking at like
a guy like uh Warren Buffett who's got
billions of dollars that he doesn't know
what to do with right now because he's
stuck in that that old mentality
meanwhile the stock market was up 20%
last year and and people are just
eclipsing his rate of growth because
he's kind of that that old school
investing and now it's it's less
fundamental this is what I write about
probably the most is is getting away
from fundamental analysis and looking at
technical analysis and what's really
driving the market these days I look at
a lot uh at volume um you look at the
algorithms that are driving the market
digging into to what really moves the
market and investing in in in those
ideas back to some of your math skills I
guess I guess so it all comes back to it
yeah interesting so uh in looking at
that uh and this is interesting so uh as
far as your philosophy here um you know
fundamental analysis you know looking at
companies which is kind of a warm Buffet
approach right I mean you have really
like you know study the company
understand the company know it's culture
getting into all the fundamentals but
now basically do you see the market as
this sort of um it's got its own
identity its own uh sense of life if you
will and that's why you can do more
technical analysis to figure out what
the market is uh how the Market's
running or what it might do for sure you
you can look at the market as as one big
ball or or many different segments you
know um fundamental analysis it's it
somebody's always doing it but to think
that I can do it any better than the
guys on Wall Street at Goldman Sachs
that are are Pros have all the tools in
there in this efficient market where
where you know information travels at
the speed of light we can't do that but
there are certain patterns that are
really obvious like right now we're in a
a strong momentum pattern and so when I
look for stocks and and and we're
killing it just following momentum you
don't look for the stocks that are doing
something different you know the stock
market was up 20% in 2019 so find the
stocks that that did better than that
figure out their pattern and don't try
to reinvent it don't try to cat you know
the falling knife um you know was a
momentum market so buy momentum stocks
until that doesn't work then figure out
that pattern and you know within that
overall orb of the stock market figure
out what works and keep doing it so
let's say that I U viewing this right
now and uh I've got uh I want to have my
own wealth breakthrough and I'm trying
and I'm a little confused or have been a
little confused about what to do I I
figure out that maybe a lot of these uh
wealth management people or advisers or
or commissioned insurance sales people
in a sense and you know they're trying
to put me into certain things and I'm
looking at the market I'm seeing people
are making a bunch of money in the
market and some people are trying to
tell me about real estate and I'm I see
all these paths in front of me so now if
I'd say you know I relate to this Andy
guy I kind of like what he's saying
resonates with me how would you start me
on the path and walk me down it sure the
first thing i' tell you is to look at at
all that investment literature you know
what are the Brokers telling you what's
the traditional financial adviser
telling you what is what is it that 90%
of people are doing identify that put it
over here and don't do that if you do
what everybody else is doing that's the
definition of mediocrity if you're fine
with mediocrity absolutely go you know
invest in those ETFs that everybody's
touting um but if you want something
better you have to by definition do
something different so start looking at
and identify those patterns that
nobody's doing if you Google something
and you know uh you know portfolio
diversification you're going to get n
out of 10 results will be the exact same
thing follow that one thing that's
different figure out why it's different
it may not work for you it may not be
right but figure out why it's different
and and and follow that path how much do
I rely on my own judgment versus uh
trusting the Judgment of of
experts 90% rely on your own you know
but you have to create uh a a good
Baseline judgment to to start from you
can't go into it ignorantly or blindly
so read books read as much as you can
read a diverse array of books don't just
figure out what you like and read more
of that read the stuff that negates the
stuff that you like and start building
on that and then you'll train your gut
there's all sorts of research that shows
why your gut instinct is so smart you
know uh it your brain can take old
patterns and and re reconfigure them
into to new information and and your
when your gut is telling you something
90% of the time is right at the time of
this recording the stock market's at
all-time highs um and and do you feel
like uh it's it has room to keep going
do you feel like maybe we're getting
ready for a correction do you have a
sense about this sure I I you know my my
what I'm on record saying is we're going
to have keep getting these all-time
highs until we get close to the election
then a politician's going to screw it up
right now um the the the the markets are
very politically driven um and and until
we you know we have all sorts of debt
issues starting to see some currency
issues that sort of thing you know none
of these problems are new but they're
going to start to snowball um interest
rates are the thing you know I always
get picked on for for my love of
interest rates I have a book at home
that's you two three inches thick on the
history of interest rates I think it's
the the greatest uh you know Financial
Tome ever written because it it explains
the evolution of of of how money has
evolved and what governments have done
to really screw it up and once you
understand that going back to that that
Baseline knowledge you can you can make
some some good decisions so watch
interest rates you know right now
they're they're falling um I'm on record
saying they're going to go negative in
the United States we one recession one
big problem away from them going
negative that's when things are are
really going to turn I think the
elections um the the variability the
volatility with the elections are going
to if if anything is going to take us
away from those record highs that's it
so interesting as you talk about the
government screwing up currency which uh
I am in complete alignment with that uh
do you have any sort of perspective on
crypto and and you know what that might
mean to the world in these markets sure
I it doesn't mean in my world it doesn't
mean a whole lot right now I love the
idea I love the background behind it I
just think the government is is is going
to be too heavy-handed and regulating it
keeping it out of the mainstream once we
see some sort of collapse or we get some
sort of political enemy really pushing
for it um then we could see it evolve
but I think the central banks are going
to go in there um you know the fed's
already talking about creating its own
form of crypto so um the idea behind it
is fantastic the the freedom the Liberty
behind it I'll I'll Stand stand behind
all day whether it turns into something
fruitful uh within our lifetimes I don't
know someday absolutely but you know the
dollar is going to have to collapse the
America's debt problems going to have to
implode then we can see that well it's
interesting you the FED uh creating
crypto it's kind of a contradiction the
whole idea is to get it out of the hands
of the government and Regulation and
make it a free currency so so it's like
they maybe are using the technology but
it defeats I think what the intention of
the whole thing is really really
interesting do youly you um give uh
perspectives for investment outside of
the market or do you basically stay in
the market most of what I write about
and talk about is is related to the
market that's my my bread and butter um
you know I've done some real estate
investing I'm a big a believer in
Farmland um one of my passion projects
we live on a farm now I I love anything
related to uh uh community-based farming
I I think uh it's it's a great uh great
way of looking at just the economy
itself uh so many of the things that are
wrong with our culture and uh our
political sphere I think a lot of that
really comes out of you know having
homegrown food understanding that um we
published something recently about how
when folks are disconnected from where
their food comes from what that does to
their psyche and I think that comes to
you know we write so much about knowhow
in manw if you don't understand what's
going on in the world around you you
can't make good decisions and and our
culture has really pushed people this is
getting kind to the the base the
foundation of manw our culture has
pushed folks into kind of identifying
themselves with with one thing like I
said in Alaska folks would get off that
plane and say hey I'm a lawyer that's
the only thing they know I think that's
dangerous the more we we understand uh
everything that's around us uh the the
smarter we'll be the the better
decisions we'll make and ultimately the
wealthier we get so to answer your
question I stick mainly on the financial
or the the stock side of things option
side of things but there's there's no no
reason that people can't get involved in
other Investments now you're you're
hitting a couple of uh positive buttons
for me because you know the whole idea
of uh you know growing your own food
living that lifestyle what's fascinating
and I'd love to see your your philosophy
on this because you're kind of
portraying a philosophical view of hey
there's there's some relationship
between how you live how you're being
maybe even
self-sufficient and what kind of habitat
or environment you create around you
uh and that does relate to your your
investing and how you deal with money
and wealth accumulation where most
people would say okay I need to read
maybe one newsletter on this subject
another newsletter on this subject
somehow you're weaving these things
together can you speak that out a little
bit sure so at manw we focus on three
things we call them our Triad Liberty
knowhow and connections and so that that
question is kind of tapping into all of
those the Liberty side of course is the
well side the knowhow side is you know
understanding so much of of what goes on
around us um you know understanding what
it takes to to be a a strong real estate
investor that ties directly over to you
know Equity buying shares of Proctor and
Gamble something like that then we talk
about Connections and that's really
where we get back to that Alaska story
and and and taking advantage of the
folks that know more than than you do I
just wrote today about the idea of of
nobody has ever built an Empire entirely
on their own you know Barack Obama got
in trouble for saying you know didn't
build that um won't get into the
politics of that um but there's a a very
strong sense that you know you can't
it's kind of the American psyche right
now that you have to do it entirely on
your own like nobody someday the the
cure for cancer is going to be really
really obvious but right now it's it's
far from obvious we have to build our
our knowledge uh you know block upon
block to get to that point and so when
it comes to investing that's a a really
important thing is to read as much as
you can take those nuggets and build on
it and then understand um you know
there's the old adage of invest in what
you know it's really important really
there's thousands of Investments out
there focus on on what you truly know
and build on that so in that respect the
grass isn't greener in the places that
you don't know absolutely go deep on
what you do know yeah stick with what
stick in your own pasture there's
there's plenty of grass there you know
it's interesting because the idea of you
know American success I think for a long
time has been about rugged indiv idual
ISM right and that and that's what you
know the country had to be built on you
know declaring an independence Etc you
had the rugged individuals that had to
make that stuff happen had that grit and
then rise but uh I know you know even
for our company we uh one of the themes
we choose we chose for this year is
collaboration so are you seeing uh it's
probably a leading question based on
what you said but are you seeing that
collaboration is really the path forward
as compared to doing it on your own I I
do um if there there needs to be that
sense of Independence that you
really the if you think of you know
collaboration that the government's
going to do it for you that's bad that's
where that rugged individualism you know
as an individual it's it's on you to
figure out your own path to success and
how to get there and how to get there
usually involves teamwork collaboration
building on other people's ideas um
coming up with better ideas you know you
put two people together they're each
going to come with their own ideas but
put them you know together and and start
brainstorming you're going to get a much
better idea so you have to have that
individual determination to go and do it
you know America wasn't built by by one
person it was boat after boat coming
from different parts of the country
building on that idea um you know going
in that Hall in Philadelphia really
brainstorming those ideas and say well
this would work this won't work I think
that's what's really important I think
we're getting away from that so many
folks just you know think the election
is going to change their life and if so
and so gets in the white house we're all
going to be rich it's not true at all
you know the our wealth rarely hinges on
what happens in Washington you know so
much of of course of politics is local
that's where that collaboration comes in
and and you know we're an individual
voice can really have some power it's
interesting how um I guess I'll call it
seductive uh you know the 24-hour news
cycle is for you know you know get you
in it get you riled up get you and uh
would you advise people to maybe tune
that stuff out and just get to work on
you know like you talking about
Washington's not going to make you rich
and maybe even having to tune that out
and tune out you know the the drama and
get focused on maybe your life your
identity and what you're trying to do in
this world absolutely we don't have a TV
in our house like we don't watch CNN Fox
News I kind of enjoy traveling because
then I can admittedly binge on on some
crappy TV but you know this is what I
learned in Alaska we didn't have you
turn the radio dial you could spin it
from one end to the other nothing you
know I was up there during the the 2008
election didn't miss a thing you know
left under one regime came back with
another nothing changed I didn't miss
you know having Fox News telling me what
to think or CNN telling me the other
side of things it it it's dangerous you
you don't want somebody telling you what
to think especially if all they're
trying to do is sell radio spots and
Commercial spots you need to get out
there read some books figure out what
you believe in and I'm not saying don't
get involved in politics just the
opposite you have to know what's going
on but you have to know what's going on
from from basically the the side of the
truth um understanding you know
firsthand what happen I went to the FDA
last year um and and spoke about CBD and
some of the issues there get involved um
you know I I took a team there and we
came back we were just shaking our heads
at at you know there's thousands
millions of folks relying on them to
make a decision and some of the
questions they asked us were just they
needed to know those answers ahead of
time so I think if people really saw
what was going on they tune out the
election they tune turn you know tune
out of the news and go about their own
thing what caus you to go down there
what was it you needed to do sure I
wanted to go down there and represent
andw readers so I I I pulled the
readership asked them what they thought
about CBD some of their confusion um and
and how they thought we need to come out
of this prohibition of of a of a plant
that was legal and and a big part of our
industry you know for hundreds of years
and so I I took a bunch of comments down
there and basically just read off what
readers were thinking added my own um
thoughts to it and kind of spun it all
together into a almost finger point at
the FDA for not making better decisions
and not being more informed when when so
many folks are depending on them to make
smart decisions that was really the the
the the grasp of the whole thing was
that this body was was making very
important decisions that affect the
lives of folks and here's this board
that's really ignorant on the decisions
they're making they're relying on
information um coming to them from the
scientific Community but for 80 years
they cut off that information you know
the the prohibition of cannabis
marijuana there's virtually no studies
China is is those countries are doing
the studies and and putting us to shame
when it comes to potential cures and
here we have this kind of arbitrary
prohibition that didn't work out so well
and so we went down there and kind of
poked holes at at at a hearing and and
and got some good attention we got some
Nationwide or a global press out of it
um and I think we we helped move the
needle um so that's something I'm really
proud of you should be and I guess you
know the good news is uh the bad news is
they were woefully inadequate in their
understanding the good news is though
that they received you and that maybe
you moved the needle a little bit and
that that at least that process still is
available to us yeah and I think that's
something we really have to to protect
and and 100% you're right that you know
the government still is is by design by
that 250 year old design has to listen
to us and and we really as As Americans
as voters we have to keep pushing to
make sure that those ideas stay there
and that we can continue to to get our
voices heard we don't just have you know
uh a news Outlet telling us what to
think and and the decisions being made
behind closed doors very important yeah
and uh very admirable that you took the
time to go do that and to represent you
the community that you built and so
let's talk about that for a moment um
you know you said there's kind of like
three guiding uh areas or principles
that you use um this is it sounds like
and tell me if I'm wrong it seems like
it's about community building in man
we're digest it's about saying hey we're
going to have a conversation and we're
going to build the community and it
doesn't sound like you're trying to
appeal to as widen audience as possible
but literally you just have a vision and
a direction and the people that want to
come on that Journey can for sure the
the our audience is is folks that that
want to be better want to do better and
want to learn more if if if you're
closed-minded you're not going to enjoy
what I what I write because I I write
things that that push the boundaries
that that tell the truth and if if
you're stuck in that conventional
mindset and this is it you know this is
what the TV told me to believe this is
what I believe you're not going to enjoy
it but if if you truly want to get
better if you're goal for 2020 is is to
make more money be healthier um and get
more done we write a lot about
productivity um then you're absolutely
going to enjoy it and and to do that you
have to have that that open mind um you
know we have we have core core
principles to be sure we have very I I
think our our political views are are
pretty obvious to anybody that reads
more than two or three uh essays um so
we have those core principles but you
have to be open to other ideas and and
let them inform your own ideas so it
seems like you still have a lot of
passion around this you've been doing it
for 15 years you you said uh so what
keeps you excited and where do you think
this is going to go sure I'll answer the
the second question first I don't know I
I want it to go as as big and far as it
will naturally go I'm not going to push
it I'm not going to do anything that
that doesn't make sense for for our
readers for our overall you know our
core beliefs um but what what pushes me
I got a note the other day we had a
trade um in in 48 hours an options trade
went up 100 50% it happened just like
you know the technical charts would tell
us and I got just a bevy of notes and
one of those notes was a guy that just
bought two options contracts couple
hundred bucks it was his first trade he
absolutely nailed it and so many folks
are afraid to make that that first trade
they think they're going to they lose
their money they think you know they've
been trained that that options are bad
or that trading's bad they just need to
buy an ETF and hold it and so much of
that's wrong that's that that knowledge
that 90% of people are are going with
but but seeing notes from folks that say
you know you really changed my life or
you turned my 401k around that's really
what what drives me that that financial
side of things is is definitely the
underlying uh you know theme in
everything I do your enthusiasm for what
you do is is contagious uh and uh I I'm
really um heartened to see you know kind
of the purpose that's driving all this
and and the experience that drives it
all and how it's serving people out
there in the world so uh it's it's a
different view I think of of wealth and
wealth development and how it might
happen and how your personal story kind
of ties into it so I very much
appreciate you taking the time to sit
and share it all well thank you it's fun
to share it we are over the moon excited
about the feedback we're getting from
the wealth breakthrough series and I
want to give a very sincere and special
thank you for those who bought the
series it supports us supports our work
allows us to get this out to the world
for free so people everywhere can have
their wealth breakthrough but for those
who bought the series it's especially
heartening to us to be able to know that
you're supporting this work so we can do
what we do every single
[Music]
day welcome back next we have Brian
pagee founder of B&B formula here to
show you how you can tap into the
billions per year Travelers spend on
Airbnb to stay in home homes it's an
incredible wealth hack Brian can even
show you how to find homes for rent rent
them out then list them on Airbnb to
make up to thousands per month it's
simple it puts automatic cash in your
pocket here's Brian with the full
story Brian thanks so much for taking
the time to talk to us glad to be here
so let's talk about uh what got you
doing what you're doing today like what
led up to this I started as a real
estate investor right out of college I
didn't really want to have a traditional
job I wasn't very good at holding a job
down I got fired from basically every
every uh employment situation that I had
so I was looking to be an entrepreneur
and I got into real estate that's how I
started as a real estate investor what
cut you into real estate you know I was
just researching how people become
wealthy I I spent a summer after college
doing an internship and I had a lot of
free time after work I was um an intern
at Hilton Resorts at Hilton Head Island
in South Carolina and so I started
reading all these books on making money
in the stock market making money
investing and in real estate and
I learned that most people either hold
their wealth or become wealthy through
real estate and I thought that might be
what I wanted to do you know it's
interesting Cu uh you know with the
concept of wealth breakthroughs you know
I see people approach this from
different ways um some are uh you know
theyve got a passion and that drives
them into a particular business and
industry uh and others like yourself
saying you know I I want to have
Financial Independence you know be
wealthy so let me go and study you know
the most uh the highest probability ways
I can get there so it sounds like that's
kind of the path you took yeah yeah I I
really wanted to just find something
that was kind of tried and true and
something that wasn't too difficult to
follow in someone else's path and I also
wanted to create cash flow because I
really wanted Financial Independence
which is totally different than wealth
building and I think that's what
everybody should aim for can you make
the distinction so how are they
different most people when they aim to
be wealthy they they decide you know I
want this kind of net worth I want us be
worth X millions of dollars or have a
certain amount of money but what they
don't realize is that if you have a
certain amount of cash flow to pay for
the lifestyle that you want then you can
be what most people call financially
independent right and that number might
be a lot lower than what most people
think of like when I get $5 million then
I'll be where I want to be financially
so I think cash flow is something that
is different for each person but if you
can create that cash flow in your life
you can have Financial Freedom so with
uh real estate how do you create cash
flow at of real estate or how did you
when you start out well I did it the
traditional way so most people would buy
property and then rent it out and make
cash flow that way I was also flipping
properties which wasn't really cash flow
but I was making pretty good money doing
that I was doing all the traditional
real estate models but it was after the
real estate crash around 20002000 20072
2008 that I had to start over MH and so
coming out of that was very painful I
was going to say was it a really tough
time for you it was very tough like were
you caught off guard and you know were
you holding a lot of stuff I mean
everybody was making money on the way up
everybody and when it crashed um I it
took me off guard I was into speculative
real estate pretty pretty heavily and uh
I was caught like uh uh Warren Buffett
says you know when the tide goes out you
see who's who's naked right so the tide
went out uh at the real estate market
and a lot of people lost everything and
I lost everything and so my whole
portfolio and and of course my credit
was decimated and I had no money and so
I had to start over and so for several
years I was trying to figure out what
that thing would be and I didn't really
want to go back into debt again I didn't
want to go back in and do traditional
real estate and so was just looking for
I guess a hack and I found that hack
through short-term rentals through
Airbnb and that's kind of where I
started down that road how
psychologically do you get past that so
here you are you you you get out of
college you say I want to generate
wealth I want to be financially
independent yeah and uh and you you're
successful you got
momentum seems like you figured it out
right like okay I did it yeah and uh
then everything you lose everything
including your credit which is very
important if you're going to try to get
started again and uh so uh so how did
you psychologically find a path forward
to be able to even start exploring new
ideas well you know it was very painful
because I I thought I was a big shot I
became a millionaire in my 20s doing
real estate and when that all got taken
away from me I mean I was in the hole it
wasn't just that I was back to zero I
was I was um severely um in a bad spot
financially and in debt and all that
kind of thing so I had to find a way to
start over and for me it was it was
realizing that with this new sharing e
with the new gig economy whatever you
want to call it that you don't need any
of the traditional um things that you
need with most investing in fact you can
leverage other people's assets to create
money in your life and that's what I
found right away is that I could
approach people that had homes that had
properties and leverage those to create
cash flow in my life and that was how I
was able to become financially
independent the second time so what was
that like so okay so you're showing up
saying here I am with no money no credit
but I've got an idea oh it was it was
not easy yeah so I can imagine what that
might have been like but so what was
what was the idea exactly you said you
know I think I can probably piggyback on
on this thing so walk me through the
thinking process okay so it's
essentially what it is is this rental
Arbitrage so just like you take
something wholesale and sell it for
retail well the same thing here I'm
taking a property that's for rent for
say $1,000 a month I turn around put it
on a home sharing site like Airbnb and I
make $3,000 a month I I pay the owner
what they're asking $1,000 and the
difference I get to keep playing that
Arbitrage and the reason that you make
more on a site like Airbnb is you're
selling it that property by the night
and you're paying for it by the month so
there's a tremendous spread there that
you can make money and the amount of
cash flow that you can make on one
property is significantly more than if
you're just a traditional real estate
investor so I was being able to do that
by approaching owners and saying hey I
have this crazy idea but if you'll work
with me I know it'll work and I could
speak their language because I was a
landlord myself in the past and so you
actually say that you generate more
Revenue doing this than when you're
having to take the risk going to debt
you know if you're flipping a house
putting in all the money the time the
rehab it Etc you're basically just
you're taking existing assets other
people put their money into yeah and
then you're just uh you're just you're
figuring out like you said it's like an
Arbitrage you're just saying I'm going
to buy it kind of uh wholesale and I'm
going to sell it peace meal at a retail
price yeah not just a little bit more
but you know an order of magnitude more
so 10 times more for an example if I
were to take a studio apartment or
one-bedroom apartment when I owned it
and I rented it out long term I'd make 2
250 a month whereas now I can make
$2,000 net on a one bedom place so it's
just there's no comparison between the
old way and the new way and also with
the traditional model you have to come
up with a down payment so you're going
to buy you put down 20% you buy the
property you got to have credit all
these different things and there's
nothing wrong with that it's a great way
to build wealth is to own property and I
do once again own property but this
allows anybody to go turn someone else's
asset into their cash flow and I don't
know if any way to do that except
through this new sharing economy and the
homeowners you know the people who are
actually renting to you are they okay
with you going because if they're
renting monthly do they also rent uh
nightly they just it's it's they have
two prices quoted or they just want to
do the monthly rental no I'm just
looking for a traditional landlord
that's looking for a one-year lease and
I sign a one-year lease with them but I
get written permission to do home
sharing so they know upfront exactly
what I'm doing and then there are owners
that I'll partner with so if an owner
has a place for rent and they're not
really sure if they want do this with me
because it's too out there then I can
partner with them and I can say let me
put your property uh turn it into a
short-term rental and then we'll split
the revenue 5050 so they make more than
they would normally and I make money
with no money out of pocket no no
deposit no long-term commitment no lease
so there's def several ways to do this
was Airbnb kind of an inspiration to
kind of look at that and say God look at
what these guys are doing I could
probably do that uh you know in the way
that you're doing it yeah yeah well I
use Airbnb as the platform there are
other sites there's vrb there's a bunch
of sites like this and and the really
interesting thing is it's expanded Way
Beyond property so now there's ways to
do this with cars you can use sites like
turo there are sites where you can make
money with your backyard or with your
raw land you can turn Yachts or RVs into
income uh you name it I mean just about
anything now can be shared and turned
into cash flow yeah and you keep
referring to the the the sharing economy
uh in a prior project we we interviewed
Paul Zay pser The Economist about you
the whole sharing economy theme so on
the macro level it's it's a fascinating
thing to see how it it's emerged yeah
the uh the demand though is the demand
really constantly there uh do you find
yourself sometimes saying well you know
I rent this place for a month or for a
year and you know it's not meeting the
the demand's not meeting our needs or is
it still robust that's a good question
well the number of users is growing as
fast or faster than the number of
providers the number of people that are
providing the homes providing the the
underlying thing that you're going to
pay for a rent so uh we're are not yet I
don't believe we've entered the maturity
yet for the market there's still
tremendous um opportunity and if you
look at all these sharing economy uh
companies that have come on online most
of them only been around about 5 to 10
years so not very long so we haven't
entered that maturity yet and they're
expanding very aggressively so there's
plenty of opportunity are there certain
profiles you look for as far as regions
or do you do cities only or you know
immediate suburbs or how how do you
figure out where to go with this well I
started locally and I most I recommend
most people start locally wherever you
live but I now have taught thousands of
people over the world how to do this and
I've seen that there's really no
correlation between how well somebody
does and the size town they live in so I
have people that are in rural areas
small towns that are doing well large
metropolises large cities different
countries not just in the US so that and
the other thing that's really
interesting is it's not just tourist
destinations I live in a touristy area
we're here in New York there's
definitely a big destination but it
works in places you would not think it
would work and the simple answer for
that how is that possible well it's
because you are serving essentially the
same purpose hotels serve and if you
look at where hotels are located they're
located basically everywhere they're on
the side of the highway they're in small
towns they're in big towns those are
people that are looking to travel short
term and guess what people are also
looking to short uh travel shortterm on
Airbnb and vbo for various reasons Way
Beyond just tourism well let's let's use
me as a as a case so I'm going to get
some free advice here so through
whatever circumstances I'm I'm holding
two homes in New Jersey in the suburbs
of Manhattan but it's still a little bit
of a trip and as you're saying I'm like
oh yeah yeah there's this hotel over
here this motel and they seem to be
actually pretty full and pretty busy but
I'm looking at you know Suburban town I
I wouldn't think there'd be much demand
and uh and I'm running you know rents
right now that have me at at a negative
cash flow um you know just that are long
term yeah so should I start to be
thinking about my lease comes up you
know on these rents uh I maybe should go
into short-term rentals and see if we
can actually turn this into a positive
cash flow situation you certainly should
in fact your cash flow I would say
conservatively could be 200 to 300% more
so if you're doing $22,000 a month you
could look at four to 6,000 as a
short-term rental that's pretty typical
so it's tremendously more money now
would you have to furnish it yes you
would have to furnish it if it's an
unfurnished place right but the uh the
net cash flow is cons considerably more
so it's definitely something that that
some owners are doing now and I would
suggest that people take advantage of
does it work on different size scales
because one of the houses uh which you
invested property from a long ago but it
it you know it's a smaller two-bedroom
place that maybe lends itself to a
little bit more the other ones you know
five bedroom 5 and a half bath the
bigger place do do people rent those
types of places yeah I I found that
anything from I've done everything from
very low income areas very inexpensive
places for example I have a
three-bedroom house that goes for $99 a
night which doesn't sound like much but
you do that times 25 days a month maybe
a couple hundred on the weekend it turns
into some serious money so that's a a
lower income area and I also have luxury
properties so I have a multi-million
dollar home that I don't own that's in
Scottdale Arizona and we do very well
with that over $100,000 a year on that
one property wow and now we're looking
at uh a bunch of properties in Florida
that are also luxury properties and then
of course I have some in the in the
middle as well so anything from low
income all the way up to luxury can be
put on these sites and turned into
essentially an income stream and you
said you use mostly Airbnb as the uh the
platform I do yeah so this is
fascinating because I know so many
people entrepreneurs that want to you
know same kind of a disposition saying I
really want to work for myself uh I'd
like to generate cash flow um I don't
really have a great idea and I don't
have any capital resources to go invest
in something so this is like it sounds
like the investment is little to nothing
to get in and and you can create cash
flow in the next 30 days so I'm a big
fan of Robert kosaki who I think you had
on the show as well or one one of your
other shows we interviewed for one of
our other Series yeah and Robert kosaki
talks about you're out of the rat race
when your passive income exceeds your
monthly expenses well I don't know of
any other uh vehicle where you can do
that with one or two moves So within
just a couple properties you can get two
or three of these properties on Airbnb
and be generating more than the typical
American makes in a year full-time so I
was able to do it in four properties so
by the time I got four properties I was
able to replace the income from my
full-time job and I was working 50 hours
a week doing that down to 3 or 4 hours
per week managing my properties which
weren't even mine they were just
managing my Airbnb so the time savings
first of all to be that wealthy with
time was tremendous for me because my my
dollars per hour went stratospheric but
then also be essentially out of the Rat
Race within just a few months um and not
only have I done this I've had many many
students that have done exactly that so
for somebody that's starting now with
nothing and wants to get out of the Rat
Race I don't know if any faster way to
do it you know it's one of those almost
sounds too good to be true kind of
propositions because you know as you
describe it but let let's let's do a a
walkr so okay now uh I'm I'm watching
this I'm hearing what you're saying I'm
like oh my God I would love to do that
yeah but now I you so now my first step
is to identify some properties sure I
guess right so where do I go to identify
properties I I look uh you know for
rental pools online realtor.com or you
where would I go there's two main
sources there's online and offline so
online could be any number of sites for
your local area it could be anything
from Zillow to Craigslist to your local
paper um that's online any kind of
online Source there's if you just Google
your city and and rentals you're going
to find all kinds of long-term rentals
so that's where you start online um
endless sources there and depending on
what country you're in you might be
looking at other sites um in Australia
for example than you would here in the
US and then there's offline um leads and
that would be driving neighborhoods
looking for for rental signs uh looking
for anything um that's out and about so
you go you go to a Real Estate Investors
meeting for example and find a real
estate investor that's a great source
because usually a real estate investor
is going to have many properties so if
they have 40 properties and they're like
hey I I got a couple vacancies coming up
next month you want both of those and so
you get multiple properties from one
owner so there's online there's offline
sources really anywhere you would look
for a rental to live in that's what
you're going to look for rentals to do
this with do I need to have some amount
of credit worthiness you know if they're
going to rent me a property I guess I
mean you you because you understood it
probably were able to talk the answer
would be normally yes but if you do what
I teach uh you don't have to even have
that I was able to do it with my credit
being essentially decimated that's what
I was wondering saying why you know
somebody had to take a a chance on you
saying I'm going to you know you're not
showing the wherewithal to be able to
honor the terms of the lease but
nonetheless I'm going to bank on you
well there is no lease because there's
two ways to do it so the way I do it is
I approach it as a service so if I'm
approaching you as an owner and I say
you know you're asking $11,000 a month
for your property what if I get you
1,500 a month with no extra work on your
your part no extra liability no extra
risk I'll do all the work and we'll do
month to month so at any point if you
don't like the way this works I'll just
walk and and we'll part ways who would
say no to that so now you're not going
to check my credit I'm just going to say
okay I'll be here tomorrow and I'll take
photos and we'll get this thing listed
let's say it's a furnished property
right so we we sign a deal you sign a
piece of paper and We're Off to the
Races so I'm offering you a service
right so there's no lease there's no
deposit there's no first month's rent
there's none of that and you'd be
surprised how many owners will take that
take that deal so so that case you don't
need any credit uh I was actually able
to get owners on board with doing leases
with me even with my credit being bad
and that's a whole another discussion
how to do that but it is possible to do
it even when you're you don't have any
credit is your preference the the joint
venture with the owner as you just
described or just say you're just going
to walk in take the lease and take over
but they you in the lease you have to
have permission to sublet I guess well I
prefer leases because a lease gives me
full control over the property for a
year and all the profits 100% of the
profits because I'm not giving them
anything beyond what they're asking for
they're just getting a great tenant
they're getting me as a tenant right uh
when I go with a partnership then I've
got to give them some of the The Profit
the advantage of course is there's no
commitment on my part and there's a lot
less money involved so it just depends
on what model you want I like to do
leases because I know for sure I'm going
to make money with it and I don't mind
signing a lease but if people are risk
averse they might want to try the
partnership model yeah do you ever uh
run to difficulty with people saying you
I don't want nightly renters in here uh
so you have to find the person that's
got a disposition say I'm okay with
letting you subet yeah you know don't
misunderstand me there will be people
that say no I'm not in any way
interested in this but there are people
that say yes and you don't really need a
whole lot of yeses to start adding up to
some serious income so I just approach
people and I play it as a numbers game
and um some people are going to say no
and some will say hey that sounds
interesting let me consider that and
I've Gotten Good at explaining them why
they'd want to go with me over any other
tenant what is the uh bandwidth on this
like how many properties can the Aver
average person kind of manage you know
in this scenario that's a good question
so I started getting when I first
started out I I got about three or four
properties and it started to get a
little bit unmanageable because at that
point let's say you have four properties
so every night or every other night you
have four sets of guests checking in
four sets of guests checking out that
happens every day or two so essentially
what you're doing is you're running a
hotel except your rooms are distributed
so we're here in a hotel right now all
the rooms are one location they have a
front desk that manages everything you
don't have a front desk you are the
front desk so what I had to learn early
on was how to Outsource all that because
I didn't want a job so I found a way to
create what I call a virtual front desk
and the virtual front desk is just what
it sounds like it's a front desk that
manages all the the guest communication
the cleaning company that has to come
and go any kind of things that might
break on the property handyman services
all that kind of thing but you can do it
all virtually nowadays right for a few
Pennies on the dollar you can Outsource
all of that work all the day-to-day
tasks and so my job simply becomes
looking for more properties so you're
able to leverage your time that way
and essentially take a step back so now
you can start acquiring more properties
and it's really just a matter of how
many you want to get I mean you could
get dozens you could uh there's quite a
few people that are doing over a million
dollars a year on Airbnb now with 40 50
60 properties but I would say the
average person if their goal is to for
example do $100,000 a year they're
looking at about four to six properties
that they can manage in order to make
$100,000 a year and that's kind of where
I started that was my goal was to do a
sixf figure income and um I did that
actually within um 6 months my first six
months on Airbnb so now um if I'm a
student like I show up and say this
sounds great yeah I got to do this um
what's the timeline in training how long
does it take me to learn to really do
this properly before I'm I'm actually
starting my first house that's a loaded
question if you're going to do it
without me I'm saying no that's fast I I
actually take people through an entire
training where I teach them how to do
this so usually I'd say it's about 60
days 30 to 60 days most of my students
get their first listing in the first 30
days and then they're working on their
second listing by the end of 60 days so
I would say it takes two months to
really understand the process and how it
works and how do you communicate with
these guests and how do you fill your
calendar and kind of working all the
Kinks and a lot of people are doing that
while they're working a full-time job so
they're doing on the weekends they're
doing in their spare time yeah so and so
I'm guessing or now I was guessing but
now I know there's Nuance here it's not
like it doesn't take a week I could
train you it's if it's 30 to 60 days
there's a lot of little Nuance that that
mat
to make this work right otherwise it
could not work out so well yeah it's
it's not it's not difficult to do but it
is complex because you have a lot of
moving parts now it's not complex when
you have one or two listings which is
probably 95% of people on Airbnb only
have one or two listings once you go
beyond that and start scaling that's
where you need systems because it's all
about scaling is where you make money in
any business and that's the key here is
understanding that now I have to imagine
Airbnb likes this right I mean it gives
more properties on their platform uh
more offerings for the people who are
showing up up uh so do you find that
that's true I'm assuming it but I don't
know it I would say they mixed on that
and the reason is because
Airbnb essentially presents itself as a
company that helps people make money
with their own house or with their spare
room or it's kind of a side gig a side
hustle not so much geared towards Big
operators or people that are going to
build a big business on the site
although that's where a tremendous
amount of the uh bookings and revenue
comes in on Airbnb is from large
operators so really it can be both it
can be a side gig or can be a big
business well I've noticed you you
brought up Robert kosaki earlier so we
went down to Arizona to you Phoenix area
Scottdale to interview him and uh we
what we did is we rented a house on
Airbnb brought the crew in you the full
phone so we had enough bedrooms for the
film crew a place to film him etc etc
and I noticed that this particular
Airbnb this house that it was one uh it
was branded because they had multiple
homes so are they do you think they're
they're doing what you do or do you
think they own the homes because I'm
sitting there saying wow they just built
the business inside of Airbnb where
they've got homes probably five or six
them around Scottdale and and it made me
think when I go back I'm going to look
for one of those places because it was
set up right it was nicely you know done
it was clean you know all the all the
things that you care about and I was
like I can't believe somebody's building
a brand within the brand so is that sort
of what you what you do I mean uh would
people know your brand on airb b or
would it just be kind of invisible you
were probably in one of my business
partners properties so I have partnered
yes now I don't brand my own airbnbs but
I have a business partner and we we've
now it was a former student of mine who
started doing Properties in Scottsdale
and so uh we have 18 Properties in
Scottsdale in the greater Scottsdale and
and Phoenix market so you may have
stayed in one of ours and uh now is that
house owned by your partner or no none
of them are owned wow they're all leases
wow so you know five to $110,000 a month
leases and up and um it's a very hot
Market it's a Scottdale is one of the
best luxury markets in the country yeah
and you may have stayed in one of our
properties yeah wow so so there's few
ways to skin this cat I guess there are
yeah that's the great thing it's it's
open to really anybody some of that has
uh more money that has the ability to
invest a large chunk of cash they could
do that in a in a luxury property
without the risk of having to go buy
that property and that understanding and
and sure of the market and it's also
open to to anybody on the lower end as
well and it's it's really all just
completely relative to whatever the
market rent is so you can make $1,000 a
month or you can make 7 $8,000 a month
on a property depending on what the
market value of that property is so uh
now somebody's watching this again I'm
trying to think like them and they're
saying so I didn't miss it right there's
still going to be demand and there's
still there's still an upside uh with
this it's not saturated at this point
for entrepreneurs coming in and saying
I'm going to do this model no not at all
no there's definitely the the recent
stat that I read is that there's a
million new users users per week signing
up to use Airbnb for the very first time
a million a week a million per week wow
yes that's what the current stats are
and that's worldwide but uh the thing
about Airbnb is the awareness now is
very high so if you were to ask 10
people have you heard of Airbnb most of
them would say they've heard of Airbnb
when you ask 10 people have you stayed
in an Airbnb it's very very low yeah so
awareness is high adoption is low and
that that um basically shows us that
we're not anywhere near a maturity level
yet and I have to imagine this is where
I I if I were you know an Airbnb
shareholder yeah if I were somebody that
was invest there I'd say I'd be
encouraging this kind of behavior
because I think it's creating Demand
right the fact that more properties are
coming on and that they're in all these
varying regions and and uh you know
that's creating more Demand on my site
and I'm getting a piece of all that yeah
Airbnb is getting a piece of all that
and we're not taking advantage of
anybody we're letting know the owners
know right up front what we're doing
everything's in the open everything's in
writing we make sure that we protect the
owners so I go so far as to ensure the
property so I ensure it for any damages
if they were to burn to the ground the
owner gets paid off if somebody were to
Sue I get liability coverage we make
sure everything every eye is dotted
every T is crossed so that there's not
going to be any issue for the owners and
so you know this is something that
there's a demand and we're we're
fulfilling a demand that's out there and
providing a service and so we make money
and the owner's happy and Airbnb is I'm
sure very happy and do you find the
owners are like you know I would never
want to mess with that so I'm happy you
you're doing as compared to them saying
Oh that's a good idea I think I'll do it
you know I've been asked that before of
all the people I've met with and I've
met with hundreds of owners face to face
now I've never had somebody say you know
that's a great idea I'm going to go do
that right now because if they were
going to do that they probably already
would be doing it and most owners they
just want one thing they want to have No
Vacancy and they want to have a tenant
that's going to take care of the
property and pay the rent on time that's
what they're looking for and they really
just want to avoid one thing and that's
vacancies and they may have multiple
properties so they're just trying to
keep keep those things full and the last
thing they want to do is start a new
Venture a new side business and they
might not even have a system to manage
them so they're they're not really
interested in that how much longer you
think this is going to run before we get
to kind of like uh where supply and
demand start start to equal out you know
you got me it's hard it's hard to even
say I I I wouldn't know how to answer
that question I you think it's years at
least oh yeah definitely years yeah I
mean I remember when Airbnb was was very
um new on the scene people were like
this isn't going to last it's not going
to work there are some challenges we
should talk about with with regulation
you know there's a lot of regulations
just like there is with Uber and all
these sharing uh apps and those kind of
things but the interesting thing is that
about 90% of towns and cities in the US
that we researched we hired a research
firm allow home sharing so we're sitting
here in New York for example New York is
not a very good City to do short-term
rentals in it's very very restrictive
but there's very little of any
restrictions in other areas that are
within a short drive of of the city
right so I have students here in New
York and they simply go across the river
to New Jersey and they get listings in
other locations so the key is to knowing
where you can do it yeah I have to
imagine Homeowner Association rules you
know I live in Park City Utah I know
some areas you got to have month or more
yeah the HOAs demand that some areas
they can do nightly and some are weekly
so it's just what part of the town are
you in it's a resort Town yeah it's just
like any real estate you know you can't
do commercial real estate operations in
a residential area you can't live in a
commercial District there's there's
limitations and same thing here there's
limitations but uh that's no reason that
anybody should not look at this as an
opportunity there's massive opportunity
here so I'm somebody out there searching
again uh what's the most important
question I should ask you I would say
how can I learn what you're doing how
can I jump in on this yeah and and so
you started out doing this yourself
you've now are teaching it how many
students have you taught uh we're
approaching 8,000 people around World
wow so there's a big appetite for it oh
definitely definitely yeah people are
hungry for this and and a lot of people
have been successful that's the thing
that really excites me is I've had
teenagers that have been killing it on
Airbnb and I have people in their 70s
that have never done anything with real
estate never done anything with didn't
even know what Airbnb was and they've
got property so they're doing well I was
just about to say my next question is
like who who's your typical student like
who's showing up for this you know it's
it's there isn't really anybody typical
every kind of U socioeconomic background
you know 31 countries around the world
Arab be is in every country but North
Korea right now so it's really anywhere
there's English speaking people have
probably heard about me and tried this
and uh quite frankly it's it's open to
just about anybody I I had a couple of
people that didn't know how they were
going to retire the people that were in
their 70s and they literally had no plan
for retirement where planning to live
this one gentleman I'm thinking of was
going to live with his kids and he was
in a small town in Georgia and he took
my training finally went through it
applied it now he's got three listings
makes about 3 to 4,000 a month net and
he said you saved my retirement so I
believe it's a retirement solution for
people people and it's also just great
for Millennials and young people who are
the main users on Airbnb and they want
to create income with the gig economy
and they're doing it and that
anticipated my my question because I
would I'm thinking like the Avatar in my
mind for this is a millennial right uh
but I also in the conversations we've
had during wealth breakthroughs with so
many people uh there's a real challenge
uh especially here in the United States
with people not being ready for
retirement they're at retirement age not
even close to ready they don't really
have the resources to go it's a crisis
it's a retirement crisis right now most
people are not prepared and and just
like I mentioned at the beginning of the
interview most people say well once I
have a million dollars and I can live
off that interest then I'll be able to
retire but I think that's a very
backwards way of looking at it's a very
old model what you want is not the
million dollars what you want is the
cash flow and the interest that that
million dollars generates which really
is not much when you think about how
much are so low very little can't even
in the even if you invest in a hot um
stock market which could go down but
when you create cash flow that's very
different you could create 2,000 3,000
$6,000 a month cash flow doing this
model through real estate but in a in a
different way through home sharing that
could immediately solve that problem and
that's what I'm finding so what we're
finding is that most people that host on
Airbnb are generally baby boomer age and
most people that use Airbnb are
Millennial or younger so that's starting
to shift but we see for me I've seen all
different ages that have been become
hosts through what I teach and talking
about
and uh I think that you said a lot of
people have it backwards right you need
to generate cash flow is a better idea
than trying to live off the interest
which which is a poultry interest at
this point yeah on whatever I mean the
type of cash flow you're talking about
you'd have to have several million
dollars in the bank to be able to
produce that much interest every single
month yeah so is there a whole reframe I
mean you the idea here wealth
breakthroughs what are the breakthroughs
that we can have what can we what's the
new understanding that we can have that
can help create wealth so when it comes
to retirement um you know do we have it
wrong do we have it backwards how should
we be looking at it well I don't know
that it's backwards because the old
traditional models still work you know a
financial adviser would tell you you put
your money into these Investments and
we're going to build a plan for the next
30 to 40 years and at the end of this
plan if it all works according to
historical averages you'll have this
much money coming in and you'll be able
to retire but what's not being taken
into account is that we live in this new
economy they're calling this new economy
and the things that are possible now
were not even possible 10 years ago so
Airbnb didn't exist 10 years ago you
couldn't have made ,000 or $2,000 a
month Forever on a property that you
don't even own that wasn't even possible
before you can make money now with with
a car you can put a car on turo and turn
your car into cash flow uh there are all
kinds of ways now to start creating
money and income in your life that
didn't exist before and they're possible
because of technology and because of the
new economy and what I call the gig
economy or most people call the gig
economy so to me it's the idea that you
don't retirement doesn't have to be
something that's out there in the future
you know if I wanted to stop working
today and just live off the money that
comes in from this new economy and what
I've created I could do that today I
could and I've seen people do it very
very young is that the idea of Financial
Freedom having cash flow that supports
you without you having to do much of
anything well I think wealth I I want to
redefine wealth at least the way I
Define it is not just income or money or
net worth it's money plus time so if you
if you're here on in New York working as
a a a stock broker on Wall Street and
you make $400,000 a year but you work 80
hours a week and your health suffers and
you do that for 30 years I don't think
that's wealthy versus you could be
making $10,000 a month working a few
hours a week traveling the world which I
know many young people that do exactly
that uh I know many airbn beers that
that do really well doing that kind of
thing and they have time freedom and
they have um Financial Freedom so it's
it's being able to enjoy your life do
things you want to do without spending
all your time working so it's more of
what you do as compared to what you have
yeah it's what you do it's it's the idea
of work less have more it's the idea
that most Millennials if you ask them
today to identify who they are to tell
you if you said to somebody who are you
and you ask a a baby boomer they'd say
I'm an accountant I'm a teacher I do
this but if you ask a millennial they
don't identify with what they do for a
living they identify with what they're
passionate about they identify with
experiences they identify with lifestyle
and these kind of things they don't so
much identify with I do this thing
because it's no longer you pick a career
and you do that for 30 years that that
that that Paradigm is over and so I
think that that whole shift is happening
that people are realizing wow there's
more to it than just yes we want to have
income yes we want to build wealth and
do all those things but we also want to
have the time to enjoy it because time
is a finite resource unlike wealth are
you looking at innovating any additional
things that maybe uh build on this or
are you just looking to expand more of
what you're doing uh absolutely I I want
to teach people how to do this across
multiple Platforms in in the gig economy
anything from making money with vehicles
to houses to anything that's kind of
along this vein and be able to to start
focusing on creating cash flow rather
than working for income so anything
that's not trading time for money I'm
about I imagine the fundamental
principles of what you're doing you know
can be transported to other sectors
doesn't have to be housing as you're
describing so once you kind of have it
wired in one place I guess that's kind
of a multiplier where you can put it in
in multiple places yeah and it's not
just in this uh this whole sphere that
we've been talking about it's also in
anything that relates to technology so
there's there's 12 and 13 year olds that
are making millions of dollars a year on
YouTube just putting you know crazy
videos on YouTube that are viewed by so
many people that they can monetize them
there's people that are creating blogs
and creating um podcasts and they have
sponsors on these podcasts I have a
podcast and they're creating income that
way so the idea that you can create
something put it on the internet and it
lives forever and it can generate income
for you you do it one time and it
generates income again and again and
again that's no different than owning a
stock stock that pays dividends but I
would argue it's better because you can
create it for free without any monetary
investment and less risk because the
stock and crash less risk and and you
know we're moving towards the value is
in the information information is the
new oil information is the thing that's
worth more than any other asset and you
can actually sell information you can
share information you can create
information and that can be sold and
that can be an asset and of itself I
think most people need to get their mind
away from the the idea that you have to
have a traditional investment to create
income and you can look at the
opportunity that exists online well you
know we know that the biggest companies
the world what are they brokering but
your information if you look at Google
Facebook Etc I mean they're they're
getting a lot of information on you and
there you look at Uber Uber is just
simply a piece of software you know and
Airbnb is a A simple piece of software
Airbnb is worth billions and yet they
don't actually own any of the properties
they're just providing a service yeah
it's that yeah Uber doesn't own a single
car Airbnb doesn't own a single hotel
and and they're worth more than any car
companies or hotels uh in the World
Airbnb just surpassed all the large
Hotel brands for Value yeah isn't it
just amazing and that did that in 10
years whereas Hilton Resorts has been
around for 110 something like that 100
years mindboggling yeah with what you're
doing specifically uh in the uh
short-term rental uh Market uh if
there's any kind of a downturn of
pullback uh is that a concern for you
well that's a good question I thought
about that and I thought after talking
to some experts uh that are in the field
we kind of determined that if there's a
downturn I think that short-term rentals
are going to do better and what's going
to happen is in a downturn people are
going to look for additional sources of
revenue they're going to turn their own
properties into cash flow and beyond
that people are going to look for more
value when they travel so instead of
spending $300 on a hotel room especially
if they're traveling with their family
they could spend 250 or 200 and stay in
a home that has three bedrooms and two
baths so on Airbnb generally you're
always going to get more for your money
than you would in the hotel industry so
I think the first to suffer would be the
hotel industry M uh whereas Home Sharing
could actually expand and do really well
in a downturn and I think that um that
the opportunity really lies there if
there is a huge downturn where people
were to lose their jobs they can
monetize their own properties they can
monetize the home they live in even if
they don't own it and I think that's a
huge opportunity for most people that
might not have any other opportunity to
create income well I find this really
fascinating and uh I guess at this point
maybe you're glad that 2009 happened and
uh you know you you were knocked off
your course to be able to put you where
you are so do you look back on that and
you're grateful for it at this point I
am very grateful and it also humbled me
CU you know I think that the the story
of any any hero's journey is that they
seem to be doing well and then they go
through that that you know pit of
despair that that low point where they
they redefine and they have to come out
the other side and uh and it's taught me
a lot about how to be content whether
you have a lot or have little and I'm
very thankful that I was able to have
success again but um yeah I would I
would say it's definitely a blessing and
definitely something I'm I'm thankful
that happened to me we're very thankful
that you uh made the trip to come here
and and sit with us and share all this I
think it will inspire a lot of people
and I wish you continued success well
thank you it was a lot of fun and I
appreciate you have
here your wealth breakthroughs episode
10 bonus interview goes back into the
scary world of taxes starring John
Briggs are you overpaying your taxes and
basically giving the government
thousands extra every year without
knowing it and do you know how to find
out if you are John's about to show you
what you absolutely must get right about
selecting an accountant and landing on a
tax strategy that can put thousands back
in your pocket every year let's get
[Music]
started
so John thanks for taking the time to
sit and talk to us about one of my least
favorite and most important subjects in
my life
taxes so tell me how uh how did you get
involved doing the work you're doing um
I I was fortunate enough to go to a
really good University BYU they've have
one of the best accounting programs and
when I started there I had no idea what
I wanted to do um but a mentor told me I
should either go into la
or business and it just so happens that
the first business class that make you
take is accounting it's the first
subject in my life where like clicked
just it made sense to me automatically
which obviously probably tells what type
of weird human being I am but um it did
it just clicked and I just went down
that rabbit hole and through uh BYU we
they give you lots of opportunities so
I've i' I've been at deoe I've been on a
few smaller businesses local firms
before I branched off my on my own but
one of the things that in class I
remember one day uh it was a personal
fin uh personal income tax class and I
just
realized there's a lot here and I love
the idea the game of being able to take
a number that the
$79,000 page tax code uh you know they
say well it could be this or it could be
this or it could be this and there's an
exception to all of those
like oh okay there's there's there's
room here to help people um not to
mention one of my beliefs is just that
the IRS is a big bully MH and I don't I
don't appreciate that I think people
need protection so all those things kind
of just were growing in me as I was
starting this career and as I got into
it and I got my hands into it I it just
stuck like I loved it I love protecting
tax people from the big bully of the IRS
and here I am when you started out and
you're working in I think you said deoe
and uh and other tax firms yeah they're
probably fairly traditional uh in their
approaches and kind of conservative as
accountants are known to be uh so when
you branched out on your own did you say
that um you had a different philosophy
you want to adopt toward your clients
and how you're going to approach this
yeah you could say there's there's two
major flaws I felt existed in the
traditional model one is on the
efficiency of the client spend
um there're a lot a lot of I mean
they're all structured similar to big
law firms where the client pays the
billable rate but what they don't
realize is that there's this whole team
of people an army if you will of
different level people and the ones
doing most the work don't control their
workflow but they're also going to be
promoted based on how many billable
hours they have is that really so it's
not basically on your expertise but are
are you just producing in essence yeah
just like a army of monkeys basically
and then you have the one guy who has a
relationship with the client and he's
the one who signs the return but I mean
he's not even involved in the process
yeah and so here I was as this new
person this new staff
accountant at dely and I wanted to get a
promo I wanted to get a job offer I
wanted to you know all those things and
uh if I only had one tax return to work
On You' take your time because you don't
want to be penalized for being smarter
than the guy next to you uh and so I
didn't like that was one problem I had
is that that inefficiency is passed to
the client and that's not fair and the
other thing was everything was Sally
same as last year like here you go get
last year's file and plug it in like
well can I ask the client questions so I
get access to the client can I figure
out if there's something else that's
going on because if they were overpaying
taxes five years ago with this
methodology of Sally same as last year
they're going to be overpaying taxes
every single year because you guys
aren't looking into a single thing all
you're doing is well that's how we did
it last year that's that's ridiculous
has taxes been the same for those five
years oh no they haven't they change
every time there's an election cycle
yeah I think maybe we could do a little
bit more for the client and ask some
questions and because they don't
necessarily know clients don't know when
they do a transaction to grow their
business they're not always aware of the
intricacies of the tax code and they're
certainly not aware
of the exceptions and the the different
ways that those things could be
classified so they're not going to
naturally come out to me and say hey
just so you know I I bought a couple
properties this year and I decided to do
a 1031 exchange and like they don't what
they are thinking is hey I bought some
new property MH it's our job to ask them
the question so that we can take what
they actually did and get the best tax
benefit for them and I just didn't feel
like the traditional firms were doing
that so the tax code obviously is
extraordinarily uh comprehensive might
be a kind word but there's there's a lot
there and it does change you know during
varying uh Seasons you election cycles
and other changes that might occur uh to
the tax code that has to be kept up with
um and then you have these clients that
are as you're saying coming in now if
I'm hearing you correctly you know you
were kind of your hands were tied at
these firms when you came in to work at
the big firms where they just said you
know more of a factory approach let's
just move people through last year same
as last year Etc uh that became a
frustration for you are you pretty
convinced that I guess number one uh
that you could have saved them more
money and number two that uh that's a
reason maybe not to use bigger firms
which your which your thoughts around
that yeah knowing what I know now um I
am 100% convinced those tax PE those
taxpayers could have saved money if
there was an approach properly taken of
course at the time all I the only thing
that was rubbing me wrong was but we're
not talking to the client and you're the
one having me do the majority of the
work how is that how how can I get any
good benefit out of that maybe there's
big firms out there that have an
approach where they focus on protecting
the client instead of this idea that
they kind of work for the government
like if if an accountant's too
conservative what happens is they they
really just they're they want to avoid
any sort of conflict with the IRS so
that if their tax if their CL tax work
is pulled for audit they want to be able
to not have any change because to them
that's the status that's okay that's how
I do this such I do such good work that
when my returns are audited the IRS
doesn't make any changes well they're
never going to make changes if you
screwed up in the irs's favor they are
going to want to look at the areas where
you're pushing the tax code and saying
look this is this is legit tax strategy
and the client's not going to pay tax on
whatever the strategy is so I I mean
yeah I haven't seen a big firm out there
but of course now that I'm in my own
thing and focused on protecting
taxpayers I don't really know what the
big firms are doing nowadays I kind of
have this feeling though they haven't
changed from when when I used to work
for them so what's your philosophy in
your firm you when you say okay we're
going we're going to have a guiding set
of principles here about how we're going
to serve clients relative to their tax
needs you know how do you approach that
uh our first philosophy is never take a
position we're not comfortable defending
MH but I use those words specifically
because it's it is a defense and the
taxpayer deserves that type of
representation against the IRS see a lot
of people don't understand is that it's
not the irs's job to interpret the tax
code courts have done that for us their
job is to just enforce it but the issue
is that almost all the time in audit
situations they are trying to interpret
the tax Cod code so it becomes our job
as the professional for the taxpayer to
go in and say no this is how the courts
have interpreted this it's not your job
to do that you can only rely on what's
been documented um and if you don't like
it then you can take this up further and
get a better interpretation well let's
let's talk about that process so uh if
there's a debate because it really
becomes a debate right because the tax
code is uh it's not as much as it's in
print it's not really black and white as
far as how you might interpret certain
uh aspects of it and you know what what
is intended by it and of course every
scenario is a little bit different so uh
you know the idea is saying we're going
to here's the position we're taking uh
it might be a bit aggressive but we can
defend it what happens though in the
process with the IRS comes in and says
no we don't agree with your position uh
we're going to you know assess certain
amount of of uh taxes that are owed and
maybe penalties whatever that go with
that does it ever end up in court if you
don't agree or you know at what point
does it finally resolved yeah it
certainly can um but so first they'll
typically send you a letter and the
letter already has an assessment without
them looking anything at anything in
your situation they're just we think you
owe this much money pre- audit yeah and
so really you're coming in from a
position of having to defend even from
the get-go right um but yeah you go back
and forth you explain this is why we
took this position this is why it's
allowed and certainly they can say we
still don't agree with you at that point
there's a couple options that you have
what people a lot of people don't
realizes the auditor part of his job is
to keep it out of the courts because
then it they're already
overloaded and so when you keep pushing
back you can often ask for the their
supervisor to get involved because they
also don't want it to get into the court
um they also want to keep it out of the
appeal system which is the next
technical step so there is negotiation
back and forth similar to how people
make settlements and lawsuits so does
the person the first person that you're
interfacing with at the IRS can they
just say too bad this is it or must if
you request for it to be escalated must
they escalate it they don't have to
escalate it but if they don't then you
immediately go to appeals which is what
they were trying to avoid in the first
place okay so you have the right to
appeal no matter what no matter what
okay and then if after appeals you can't
come to an agreement you're still at
odds is that when you can push it into
the courts yeah and there's a couple
ways you can appeal um there's one
method of appealing uh that's like it's
a one and done if they don't take your
stance and they don't agree with it
you're kind of host and then the there's
the other way where basically you're
saying I am willing to take this all the
way through the court system all the way
up to the Supreme Court if we need to um
so that yeah you have quite a few
options and then in between the Appeals
process and courts and even even from
the beginning anywhere in that whole
process at any point you can reach out
to the taxpayer Advocate Group which is
technically part of the IRS but their
job is to kind of be like the lunchroom
supervisor you know um and so they are
much more focused on protecting the
taxpayer versus the IRS auditor just
trying to get a win and boosting his ego
no are the IRS Auditors also
incentivized in other words if they show
that they do a bunch of audits and they
don't collect any money that looks bad
that's like having a lack of billable
hours or uh I know I I can't ever get a
straight answer from them which kind of
tells me there's an answer there yes
they aren't given commissions or
additional bonuses of pay but I'm
confident there is some sort of penalty
if they don't have a certain amount of
collections we'll be like a prosecutor
not getting convictions right you
they're supposed to be prosecuting but
you know people end up innocent and
people might be innocent but it looks
bad for them if they keep getting you
know like I want to be promoted I want
to be thought of for promotion so yeah
they're
very yeah yeah it sounds like the you
know pretty uh flawed system it it is
not in favor of us taxpayers definitely
not in favor of us so I imagine there's
really two categories um and maybe even
more but that you have the people who
are
self-employed uh business owners uh
independent contractors and then people
who are W2 employees do you see that
both have a lot of room to save money or
do you think that the W2 employees are
kind of stuck where they are and they
don't have much latitude and you know
the uh the business owners are the
people that really can play in the tax
system and try to you know um save money
yeah I love trying to find ways to help
people lower taxes so much that I don't
want to make the blanket statement that
W2 people are screwed MH but they're
pretty close to being screwed um
especially after tax reform of 2018 MH
there are some changes that there was
some benefits they could have gotten and
those have just been completely wiped
out so generally a W2 person pays tax on
their W2 income now that being said I
know there are some people out there
that push this idea well if you're
W2 get a join a network marketing
company and pay this amount per month
and now you're in business and while I I
love the aggressive mindset there there
are some issues with that that we
typically try to help our clients
understand uh if you're going that route
you have to make a legit effort to try
to make money right um because it is
going to be hard for me to make a like
defend your position to the IRS if uh
you don't have a website up you've never
gone to a meeting to try to sell your
product you know um so basically one of
the places where they could start to
write off maybe a part of their home for
an office a part of their car and
whatever the things they could do is if
you're W2 employee you create a side
business yeah but it's got you have to
legitimize the fact that this is a real
side business not a a tax gimmick
exactly um I would say the safest route
for W2 people is if they can uh figure
out in their financial plan how to get a
rental property that's probably the
easiest way to classify yourself as a
business owner and then get to take the
benefits that are applied to business
taxes so that's interesting so basically
because we have you know so many people
in the series talking about real estate
and real estate investment and uh maybe
you know getting single family homes you
know and renting them out um so if if a
W2 employee does that um now they can I
guess they say they they have a business
right it provides income you know they
got to file all this stuff do you
recommend they form an entity for that
business uh you know or that they just
kind of keep it as a personal proprietor
uh um I mean it's definitely more of an
attorney question I'm not licensed so
I'll give my opinion though because I
love sharing my
opinion um I like having at least a
single member LLC and the reason I call
it that or say it that way is because it
doesn't complicate their tax filings
it's still going to be filed on their
personal return but they would get some
entity protection should their tenant
decide to sue them um plus I like the
added benefit that from the IRS side you
can say here's the business name of
their real estate business as opposed to
saying yeah they have this property it's
titled in their personal name but they
rent it out so it's just it's a little
bit of a stronger defense for us um if
that happens my show intend saying he I
plan on getting more properties when I
can and I want to grow this business
let's talk about entity structure
because that's probably important too so
I heard you say single member LLC my
understanding was that that's uh a
increases tax audit risk if they that
the IRS doesn't like single member llc's
or do do they you file it as something
other than an LLC yeah so a single
member LLC the name the IRS gives it is
disregarded entity okay meaning they
don't give it any regard doesn't exist
it's like the annoying neighbor like I'm
just going to pretend that person's not
there and so the single member LLC of
itself isn't the audit risk it's uh the
filing on a schedule C which is
generally where single member llc's are
filed that can be some increased audit
risk but with a real estate property
it doesn't go on Schedule C it goes on
Schedule E mhm which is for rental
properties and um in the tax codes you
have this it's kind of geeky um there's
really two forms of tax like income that
someone can make and so they're tax in
two different ways ordinary income so
for my tax firm the service I provide
that's ordinary income real estate
income is considered passive the big
difference between those two
classifications is that my ordinary
income is subject to self-employment tax
which currently is 15.3% that's on top
of the income tax bracket that I'm
already going to pay tax on passive
income doesn't have that self-employment
tax tied to it so the IRS is as you can
imagine more interested in looking at
numbers that have a higher tax rate tied
to them and so a Schedule E even if it's
held in a single member LLC uh doesn't
doesn't increase Auto risk so so that
seems like a really good way to uh to be
a W2 employee and to still you figure
out some tax advantages for yourself
yeah let's talk about the other side now
the business owners um you know people
who are
self-employed uh and you know maybe dig
into that a little bit first question I
have and this is maybe a general
question across the board regardless of
your W2 you know $199 self-employed what
have you um is it your opinion that that
the majority of people right now and I'm
not I'm not asking this as a leading
question even though it sounds like one
but is it your opinion that the majority
of people right now are overpaying in
their taxes absolutely so no no
hesitation no no hesitation so because
here's the thing that I find very
interesting about this
imagine that uh you were finding ways to
make more money right can we work extra
hours can we add another B you're
looking for ways to make more money when
literally you can work no additional
time time and through tax savings you're
making more money I mean it's the same
thing right it's the exact same thing so
now the follow-up question to this so
across the board most people are
overpaying in their taxes yes second
question is how much I mean I know maybe
it's a wide range but is it they a
percent or two or maybe they're
overpaying by 20% I mean what what do
you find as typical yeah I there's
nothing that's typical um it does depend
on everyone's situation uh because
there's some strategies are just they're
out there and I don't know why more
people don't use them um one in
particular we like to use in our firm we
call it corporate rent it'll save
anywhere from three to $6,000 in taxes
just by implementing the strategy but
that could be that could be a 50%
savings for them it could be a 1%
savings for them uh the way we look at
as cash is King right not not
necessarily the percentages so $3 to
$6,000 that's still nice like at a
minimum it should cover at Le part of
your cost for your accountant to do the
work for you right um yeah so I I
wouldn't I don't I don't know the if
there's a typical number I just know
absolutely whenever we meet with someone
we find something and knowing how
conservative the industry is uh
absolutely there's ways that people
could find areas I mean the issue here's
the issue is that you really do get to
the point where you feel like your
accountant is working for the government
mhm they you come in in and you're I got
this business idea or you already have
the business and hey I'm looking to do
this uh can I write that off the
conservative accountant says no ask me
some questions like figure out the tax
code is 79,000 plus Pages you can't tell
me in there there's not a tax code or an
exception to the rules that you think
you know that can't help me I mean at
least say okay what are you trying to
accomplish how could we write it off now
sometimes we go down that rabbit hole
and and they can't write it off but to
just have an accountant blatantly just
say no you can't come on let's let's
stop being lazy as accountants and let's
protect the taxpayer they're the ones
that pay our bills they're the ones we
should be serving and not the government
let's talk about the top three or five
common areas where people are overpaying
you know where they could have saved
money but they're not for sure the tax
strategy I talked about the corpor rent
strategy and so explain what that is
exactly so some people call it um on the
East Coast they call it the Augusta rule
because the Masters tournament in golf
is in Augusta Georgia every year and
what happens is these people who live
there have an influx literally like two
to three times the amount of people are
coming into their little city and they
blow it up mhm well we're like hey
there's not enough hotels in the area so
let's start running out our house kind
of like Sundance in Park City yeah yeah
yeah exactly we we should call it that
here in Utah the Sundance rule yeah
let's run out our house and I I am
willing to bet because there's wealthy
people that live down there that at one
point a wealthy person said hey you know
I think I have the clout and the strings
that I can pull to get it so that all of
us who are getting rental income down
here just for this short week that we
won't have to pay income tax on it
because we don't really have a rental
business and so the the tax rule is this
if you have a rental property and you
rent it out for more than 14 days in a
year mhm
that's that's the definition of a rental
property per the IRS standards but what
people Overlook is that it starts at 14
days or more technically the 15th day so
if I rent a property out for less than
15 days during the year it's not
classified as a rental property for
income tax purposes and that means I
don't have to claim the income that I
get from that activity so that's where
the Augusta rule comes regardless of the
amount you don't have to claim it
regardless of the amount now it has be
market rate yeah but yeah regardless of
the amount um so what happens is we say
look there's no reason a small business
can't take advantage of this rule let's
have the business sign a contract with
the individual which happens to be the
owner and say we're going to have a
monthly meeting because we're a business
and we should have a monthly business
meeting and we're going to have it at
your house but if you do that that's
only 12 times out of the year so my
business gets to expense the rent
payment because it's ordinary and
necessary meaning it's something that
other businesses do right they they rent
out big convention centers and hotels to
hold company meetings that's all you're
doing except instead of the big venue of
a conference center or hotel you chose
your house which is probably cheaper
anyway at market rate yeah and now I
guess this is where the arguments come
in what's what's one day market rate
it's probably kind of a hard thing you
know to to establish but so now here's
the question on on that particular one
then we'll get on to other ones
obviously you know the the person saying
I'm doing this and I'm doing it as a tax
strategy you know but it's permitted by
the tax code so I could just take
advantage of that so there's no so
you're you're very comfortable defending
that so if yeah oh you have defended it
okay and never a problem I mean they
fought it for like three years but we
won like it's a legit strategy
so they fought it for three years and
why did they fight it because the code
is clear that you can do
it why did they fight it I I mean
exactly I sometimes I think their tactic
is maybe we can wear them down you like
no forget about it we're the rocky b b
of tax you know we're g to keep fighting
I love it so so okay so that's one where
and it's established now through through
a three-year fight that yeah but so to
answer your question about the market
rate luckily with a and B it's actually
not that hard anymore oh that's true
Airbnb just find houses similar in your
area and pull a couple and that becomes
your documentation and proof of why
you're charging what you charged is
there another way to do this is saying
okay hey I want to do all 14 days at one
shot and uh you know uh so I'm going to
rent my house to my company for the two
weeks but I guess I have to have a a
reason that the company needed that
house for two weeks correct and that's
the thing so you definitely can if you
had a viable reason for the 14 days or
the 12 days or however many days in a
row so we do get clients at the end of
the year who this the first they've
heard about it I'm like oh how is there
a way for me to get this in well I mean
at the end of the year you do have you
have Christmas holiday parties you can
rent it out for that Thanksgiving I mean
all those types of things but yeah you
might want to plan a training seminar
just for your team even if it's you
you're still part of your team I'm going
to do a training seminar in my house and
it's going to be multiple days and
that's and this is another part of the
question uh so let's say I did the the
12 Day rental you know a day a month for
12 days uh do I have to show that I
hosted people at the house that I uh I
mean reality is we really do the this
kind of stuff in our houses I'm I'm at
uh you know my partner's house he's at
my house we are meeting actually weekly
you know at you know we alternate from
one the other they are typically all day
meetings uh etc etc um so you know I
guess I guess that kind of stuff would
be very very valid that's the funnest
part of this tax strategy is when I
first teach people about it a lot of
times they're like that that's too good
to be true it doesn't sound right but
then they they realize I actually am
using my house for business we all do if
you're a business owner you're using
your house for business it happens um
but yeah B I can tell you based on the
audit that we defended you definitely
want proof as to the purpose of why you
were there MH and if you have pictures
even better MH uh but certainly at least
uh meeting minute that reflect what was
discussed what was trained all the diff
like even if you have different
attendees you want to list all the
different people out yeah so the better
the more documentation you have the
better you're going to be able to get
through the audit if they audit you but
here's the beauty of the strategy it's
rent expense on your business return mhm
that's it it's rent expense it's a small
expense in a grand scheme of things
typically if it's only a few you 12 or
14 days yeah so it this strategy alone
of itself doesn't raise any audit
triggers because it's just another
ordinary and necessary business expense
that you have it's not like filing a
Schedule C per se or a business use of
Home form on your personal return things
like that so typically it's going to get
picked up when they're probably auditing
for other things as compared to it it
triggering an audit correct that's
interesting all right so what's another
one um you know in general actually I I
always start people because they get
they get EX oh my gosh how can I save
taxes well it's the first it's the
mindset M I'm in business and if I spend
a dollar for my business
that means it's a tax write off based on
the code if I'm spending the dollar and
it's to help my business grow or help me
grow as a business owner or help my team
grow that's a tax write-off for my
business so we always tell clients ask
yourself when you spend money is this
related to my business in any form shape
or fashion because if it is you can
defend the reason why you're expensing
it and if it's not then of course don't
pay it don't don't try to expense it but
if it is pull out your business business
card and pay for it with that um and
honestly that alone helps people find
thousands of dollars a year in missed
expenses so let's let's talk about that
for a minute because reality is for
entrepreneurs and small business owners
there's very little that we're doing
that's not somehow related to business
and I'm not saying that just for tax
purposes but to legitimately look at you
know you know what we do uh you know
when I go out to dinner with my wife
we're very often talking about we got
this trip to make for the business we
got you we're going through we're
talking about these things so you know
to me it's like yeah you know that that
that was a business conversation and you
know I work at the house I have a home
office uh I'm buying snack supplies
those are going into my office you know
I'm eating that stuff all day long you
know and so on so is that the kind of
stuff you're talking about saying that
you know we could really look at a lot
of the detail of what we're doing and if
it somehow touches the business you you
want to write it off yeah totally now
there you brought up so I just have to
bring it up there is one very black and
white exception when it's eating out mhm
even if your wife is part of the
business and it's just you and her the
tax code's very clear that that can't be
a write off so that's new isn't it is
that or is that that wasn't a tax reform
change tax reform changed entertainment
and they just said you can't write off
entertainment basically anymore at all
at all um which sucks uh but I I get it
is that if you're entertaining at home
what if I'm on a business trip I have to
eat out I mean I don't have so meals is
different than entertainment for sure
when you're travel ing uh every day
that's a travel day which is uh defined
as when you're not sleeping in your bed
so if you have a hotel right next to
your house and you sleep in that hotel
MH that's a travel day MH but when
you're when you're on a travel day all
food is a is a write-off that's meals
it's the entertainment portion so if I
go to uh a basketball game a jazz game
or whatever uh I can't write off the
cost of that ticket anymore I can write
off my food while I'm there but I can't
write write off the actual ticket um it
also means if I can go golfing I can't
write off the cost of the golf on my
green fees I can't write that off so so
this gets interesting so I'm traveling
you know East to meet with business
people uh you people I have business or
a perspective business relationship with
I can write off the plane ticket to get
there yes I can write off the meals a
meeting in the hotel but if I go do
something with them uh like go to a game
or play around a golf that's that's off
tax reform next that okay yeah and uh so
so that's all but anything that's local
you can't write off meals if you sleep
in your bed that night you can if
there's a business purpose so again if
it's just you and your wife you might
want to invite somebody else with you
because when you're audited they're
going to look at your receipts or your
documentation you would say who the
business meal was was with and so you'd
want to make sure that you have someone
else that you also part of that but so
are you saying if I have a local meal
with a business partner that's I can
write off it's just people in your
family is the is the way the code's
written yeah you're immediate family
immediate family that even if they are
business partners yeah that's
interesting yeah we call it the we refer
to it as the spouse rule I don't know
what the IRS refers it to is I don't
know but it it's annoying now on the on
the flip side of this uh and this is
something that's been confusing for me
so I imagine it's confusing for other
people maybe you can help the new tax
code has uh I think uh I don't know they
call pass through income or you know
some new form of income that gets taxed
at a lower rate like a 20% rather than
regular income you know what I'm
speaking about so talk to me about that
well let me first start with tax reform
changed corporate tax structure which
used to be a scaling thing like we have
on the personal side and they just said
it's a flat 21% MH so when they did that
I don't know what person which we're all
grateful for said well you just gave an
advantage to C corpse and and not all
the other structures because llc's
Partnerships s
corporations um those types of entities
don't pay taxes like a C corporation
pays taxes they actually don't pay any
income tax M it flows to each individual
owner and then they pay tax based on
what portion of the business flowed to
their personal return MH so there was
this you know disadvantage for them they
said okay well let's create this new
thing it's section 199a mhm and it's
also referred to as qbi qualified
business income mhm and the way it works
is if you have qualified business income
there's a bunch of rules and exceptions
on it of course but um effectively you
can take 20% of that and you get it
shaved off of your taxable income so if
I have $100,000 and that's my only
income and it's also considered
qualified business income I will only
pay tax on $80,000 of it because 20% of
100,000 is
20,000 right um but so the 20,000 is
taxed at the 21% rate and the no 20,000
is not taxed at all zero nothing zero
it's to it's just taken directly off of
your taxable income and then you're just
paying regular income tax on the
remaining 80% on the remaining 80 yep
interesting so that's a weird thing to
say just 20% of it is no income tax on
it yeah for reason they just felt like
the 20% was equivalent to the tax break
they were giving on the C Corp side is
there a ceiling on that there's not a
well meaning like let's say my income
was $2 million so I could take 400,000
okay and I don't get taxed on it yeah
yeah so I don't know if you know this
but the government really likes to screw
rich
people really yeah I had no clue I know
that's probably the biggest you know mic
drop mind
blown um and and so if your income is
above a certain threshold MH now you get
into these exceptions to this 199a okay
the but that being said the first
exception is the IRS for some reason has
five categories of businesses that they
just hate I don't know why so at our
firm we refer to them as the hated Group
Accountants are one of them doctors
attorneys I guess typically the
professionals who tend to make a lot of
money mhm now there are some who
successfully lobbied and got themselves
as an exception to the exception but
regardless if I'm in that
group and my income is above I don't
know the exact numbers because it
doesn't serve me to have that exact
number in my head call it 415,000 if my
income is above 415,000 on my tax return
they are now going to limit Andor
completely n the benefit altogether oh
wow so as as a person in the hated group
I lose that benefit once I'm above the
415 whatever that exact number is it's
around
45,000 if you're filing married um if
you're not in the hated group once
you're above that threshold then they
look at well how much did you pay in
wages um no yeah because this is only on
I I look at it as distributions but you
whatever you're on payroll for that's
not included so it's only income well so
you're w is uh your wages is an expense
um the company but if if it's your wage
then yeah you get to reclaim that on
your personal return that goes to part
of the calculation right I mean that's
on the 199a it does yeah okay and so
it's either what you paid in wages or a
percentage of your assets that you have
on your balance sheet so as for an
example if if there's a Manufacturing
Company they're not in the hated group
so if they had $2 million of income I'm
assuming a manufacturing company's going
to have a decent amount of wages
probably going to be more than 20% of
their income which means they would get
they would get the 20% reduction so I
guess at the risk of not doing the
entire segment on this know uh you know
so bottom line is you know as we're
going down listenting where could we
save money one of the places is saying
you might be eligible for this this what
you call the
199a uh income where 20% of your income
won't get tax so so basically ask your
accountant about that and and definitely
for your specific scenario for sure
because there's probably somewhere in
there not to mention you kind of want to
do that before the tax year ends because
you know I've had clients that came in
last year and they were right on that
415 bubble um in the hated group and it
made a lot of sense for them to
accelerate some expenses they were going
to have in the following year to get
their income underneath it cuz once it's
gone it's like it's not oh I get 20% oh
now I have 19% it's you get 20% taken
off or zero oh my gosh and so if you
have an asset you can buy say $40,000
worth and that keeps you in the
threshold instead of losing it like I
mean that's a massive tax swing can at
the end of day that $40,000 purchase
actually sometimes you got it for free
just based on the tax savings you kept
could I go back and file an amended
return uh for 199a you can file an
amended return okay so I can go back and
say oh I missed that and now let's amend
this and do this all right so we've got
got now this the Augusta rule you got
the 199a where else can I save taxes it
amazes me how many times I get clients
and we say how many miles did you drive
mhm and they're like I've never been
asked that before it's one of the like
most tried and true Tax Strategies is
riding off the miles you drive for your
business now people get confused because
it's like well I've been writing off the
miles uh going like the obvious ones
that people think about like oh I drove
to that client I'm right off those miles
well as we talked about in in other
sections like everything that we are
doing is related to our business so if I
have to go to Home Depot to buy
something for my business the mileage
driven to Home Depot is a tax right off
if I'm driving in my car and even if I
have my family in the car if I'm driving
say to Southern California to meet with
a client it doesn't matter that my
family's in the car those are business
Miles because the purpose was to meet
with the client in Southern California
and those miles are deduction on top of
if I'm writing off a part of a lease for
a car not exactly okay that the tax Cod
to it it's annoying um the IRS lets you
take a mileage deduction or they let you
write off what you actually spent on the
vehicle okay so if you're leasing the
car a lot of times the lease is going to
give you a better write off um but in
that you then include your gas so you
you would write that off uh Insurance
whatever all that other stuff Tire
repairs windshield repairs whatever all
right so we got cars and mileage yeah
what's another one um travel is a great
one people don't realize that if you
have a predetermined purpose to the trip
for for business then it's then you can
write it off now for example let's say I
fly my family we want to go to
Disneyland um well I don't want to go to
Disneyland I want to meet with my
clients in Southern California right or
if I'm a if I have real estate business
I want to go to California to look at
real estate down there to see if I might
buy something so I'm going to set up at
a meeting with an agent down there to
get the landscape now it just so happens
that my family's going to come with me
well that's a business trip now while I
can't write off like the cost of their
plane tickets because they're not part
of my business if they were part of my
business though I could MH you know th
those are areas now we're going to stay
in a hotel well I'm going to stay in a
hotel if it's just me or my family is
with me so I can write off the cost of
my hotel because that's an expense I
would have had anyways and so there are
often percentages of family trips that
with a little bit of preparation you can
justify his business and you can get
that written off so basically your
family can piggy back on on a business
trip uh but you just can't write off uh
their direct expenses I guess right yeah
so now that we see okay these are some
things that are areas where you can pick
up and and maybe reduce your taxes by
reducing your income through the
deductions uh any uh common mistakes you
see people making where they're doing
something on their taxes that would be
like just a really bad idea yeah well uh
I mean my first one is you if you're a
business
owner filing your taxes is the number
one biggest mistake uh because you do
one a year and if you find an accountant
they're typically doing thousands a year
so they have a little bit more
experience so don't waste your time so
don't go to Turbo Tax and say I'm going
to you do this if you're a business
owner for the love do not use Turbo Tax
oh my gosh and even H&R Block I wouldn't
I personally wouldn't go to H&R Block if
I were a business owner uh because the
people you're talking to don't they're
just not in the right mindset in my
opinion so other mistakes that we
see Schedule C is uh is a big one and
and oh some of the mistakes we see is
that we talked about a little bit
briefly where I have a I have a W2 and I
want to be a business owner so I'm going
to join a network marketing company so
now I have a really high W2 MH and I
have a schedule C Business that has a
massive loss because I'm not really
trying to grow it or make money I just
want to write off things right that
happens to be an audit trigger um is it
like in one year or if you filing
multiple years and they see just
continual losses on a schedule see yeah
is we look at it on year-by-year basis
I'm not convinced the IRS has a system
sophisticated enough to track people's
year-over-year where that gets in
trouble where people get in trouble with
that is that if IRS audits my 2018 tax
return and they see something egregious
they're going to then open up audits for
17 16 and 15 as well and that's where
sometimes people think like it's a this
history Trend thing but I don't know I
could be wrong I just based on my
interactions with the government uh I
think they're a little behind on the
times and I don't think they have the
database to track like well this was
your number on your Schedule C this year
and okay now we've looked at these three
years of data now we can we we'll
trigger not it based on looking at
multiple years I I don't I think it's a
single year instance is what they're
looking at so John so far you convinced
me that um there's a lot to know and I'm
not interested in knowing it I'm
interested in running my business so let
me ask this how would I vet the right
accountant because here's the
interesting thing it's like any
accountant's going to know more than me
at least they better right so I'm going
to be somewhat impress they know this
they know that and they're going to have
some logic behind what they do uh I I
what I really need to know though is
that um how how would I interview or
find an accountant that's going to take
a more aggressive approach without
getting me into trouble
yeah uh I think people need to ask more
direct questions for sure when they're
interviewing that there's this element I
feel like when I have taxpayers come in
there's you can tell they're intimidated
not not necessarily because I'm an
intimidating person but because it's the
subject matter it's like oh taxes it's
one of those things even I when I get a
letter from the IRS my heart will skip a
beat a little bit I'm like ah I got to
deal with these people um I can only
imagine what that is for someone who
doesn't deal with them on a daily basis
and so they have that in the back of
their head when they're approaching an
account accountant and I think that gets
in the way of a good analysis I I would
say like approach it from a standpoint
of you know how would you interview an
employee like try maybe the same
approach and go in and just think of him
this guy's going to be an employee for
me his sole purpose is going to help me
save taxes but you know I want to make
sure he fits with me culturally I want
to make sure he has some technical
knowledge um obviously they might not
understand the technical knowledge
aspect but you can ask questions let's
see what kind of questions um should
they ask so I guess I'd want to know let
me suggest them and tell me if you think
these are good questions one would be um
how many audits have you been through
with the IRS and what were the outcomes
of those audits that'd be a great
question that's a good question ask and
incidentally if a accountant or a firm
if they're giving me an attitude about
wanting to ask these questions does that
automatically disqualify them totally
yeah yep like they should be receptive
to to being you want you want to feel
like when you ask your accountant a
question they're going to respond to you
to and not make you feel
like oh my gosh I have to answer this
question this is going to be a pain in
to ass client yeah okay yeah you and
maybe that's also another thing maybe uh
call them how fast you get on someone's
schedule how fast are they responding to
your request to meet them and see if you
want to hire them send them get their
email address send them an email with a
question see how they respond to your
question and how promptly I can't tell
you how many new clients we get for the
sole reason that they say yeah after
April 15th my accountant disappears for
a month and then it takes him a month to
get back to me so I'm not hearing from
him until August you know um it's just
not appropriate so a thing that occurs
to me based on what you said earlier uh
in this interview uh that I would want
to ask because I'm curious about this
now I want to go back and ask my
accountant um how much are you relying
on last year's tax return to develop
this year's right sure uh because here's
what I do know you know approaching
April
15th you there's like an overwhelm of
activity at all accountants offices
right and I have to imagine a lot of
that's because most clients especially
business owners it's like the last
minute they're like you know I'm not
thinking about I'm thinking about so
many other things but now I'm on
Deadline and I got to get all this stuff
in so I imagine they're getting deluged
with with stuff so I have to imagine
also that the inclination is to say well
let's look at last year's return you
know they they probably still have the
same house same word same you know they
they just basically start plugging in
all the all the stuff from last year and
they're trying to get through it as fast
they can because they got a bunch of
other stuff to process is that probably
an accurate depiction that's very
accurate I mean even in our firm April
1st to the 15th it's crazy but at the
same
time that's also that's a good time to
email an accountant if you're trying to
vet somebody how fast are they getting
back to me in the heat of their season
April 1st to 15th um now our response is
hey thanks for reaching out you're on my
agenda now I will get you a question but
I have to take care of the people who
got to me first you know and that might
not go over well with some people but
I'm we're at least responding right
right so you want an accountant who's
responsive it's interesting they and I
wish I had the date or the the person to
tell you who did the survey um but I'm
aware of a survey I saw and they asked
tax like clients what's the most
important
qualifications in in an accountant
technical knowledge was like number
seven communication like promptness was
number one wow um and I think you can V
an accountant pretty good just by how
fast they're getting back to you um but
at the same time I I would I would
potentially ask questions like have you
ever heard of the Augusta rule maybe ask
what do you what do you do to stay on
top of tax reform and how do you help me
as a client when there's tax changes
like how how do you get me that
information or do you and you might if
they kind of like squirm a little
bit they probably don't do that for
their clients well I'll tell you one of
the things that occurs to me again based
on what you said earlier uh would be you
know what type of clients do you mostly
serve because there's a lot of specialty
in taxes as you said you know if they're
used to doing like one thing over and
over again over here uh or as you said
don't file own returns work with
somebody who's filing thousands of them
so they know you know kind of what might
be there the you I almost call them
tricks but you know pra best practices
for your type of person I imagine you
know it's very different when you're
working with let's call it a small
business owner who maybe has a handful
of employees or Works mostly with with
contractors versus you know people who
have $100 million businesses offices you
know uh payroll for you know large
employee pool pools those are very
different scenarios and very different I
guess types of approaches so uh is it is
are there sweet spots for um you know
different types of businesses and
different scales of businesses yeah I
mean because bigger companies are
probably doing stuff uh that hits more
areas of the tax code MH which means
there's possibility for different like
credits maybe that they might not have
been aware of that someone who's only
dealing with small business their
clients aren't even doing like research
and development but the bigger companies
are well there's you you'd want to know
that your person's familiar with those
types of things if I already ask you
this question what's your central focus
in tax what do you specialize in yeah we
specialize in small business and what I
mean by that I should actually also say
flow through entities so llc's taxes
Partnerships or S
corporations those types of entities
those are the ones we're really familiar
with so there is this idea honestly
there's about 80% of the tax code that
applies to everybody MH and so if I have
someone who comes up to me and they're a
realtor I C their tax situation we can
handle MH just like we can handle
someone who is a beautician because for
them the tax code is almost exactly the
same obviously then you'd want to know
like if I'm a realtor there are specific
realtor rules especially when it comes
to owning rental properties that you
would want to make sure that your
account knows um and nowadays with
Google like you could probably Google
like I'm in my industry real estate tax
specific and you could get a general
idea of Concepts and you could just say
those Concepts to the accountants you're
interviewing and see how competent they
seem when you bring them up you don't
have to be an expert right but with a
quick Google search you can at least
know the name like words you can use to
see if they're even familiar with it I I
had a client came come in in once and he
was making really great money filing it
on his schedule C which is a terrible
idea M and I'm reviewing his returns and
every copy of returns he gave me for the
past five years like you've you've been
filing this way for five years he's like
yeah my accountant said I don't need to
make the switch until I'm at x amount of
money I'm like okay so I gave him some
questions to ask his accountant and come
to find out the reason his accountant
suggested the schedule C is because he
didn't know how to file an S corporation
tax return oh my God uh yeah so that's
highly disturbing and isn't it isn't it
the accountant's responsibility to say
you know I'm not really that familiar
with filing these returns let me refer
you instead they just said absolutely
wow yeah because I can tell you we've
had I the only client I can recall
Turning Away uh he was a micro Brewery M
and I just I'm like I don't understand
anything about this industry I don't
have any clients in this industry MH I
understand manufacturing but you're it
just it's a little bit different based
he's even just in the initial meeting as
he's talking about his process of how
they make their product like honestly
I'm just not going to be the right fit
for you because I'm not going to be
familiar enough with the credits that
you probably are able to pull um and
yeah your account should be honest with
you like I can't that's not in my
wheelhouse so this begs another question
which to me sounds like it might be a
good business practice uh should I be
getting second opinions you you know
with 79,000 page tax code who can know
everything I mean nobody right nobody so
so now it's saying should I say you know
I've been working with my accountant now
for over 30 years which I have and I've
got um uh you know a lot of returns uh
should I be taking maybe my last five
years of returns and and showing up at a
place like you're say Hey you know I
just want another opinion I'd like to
see what somebody else thinks here are
my returns for the last 3 years or five
years uh and you know just pay some of
your for your time to review these and
get an opinion from you if you think
that we're doing it right or that you
maybe have a different strategy on how
we might approach this yeah I think when
it comes to anything with your money uh
getting a second opinion is good I'm not
saying like every month even potentially
once a year maybe not but it's just
solid Financial advice like always get a
second opinion but the worry might be am
I am I like is it going to piss off my
current if if you had how does he know
how would he even know that you got a
second opinion well because if stuff
comes back and it says uh you know I
think you could have saved money doing
this this and this I'm going to be going
back to him saying
hey you why didn't we do this sure okay
that's fair uh and and uh so I guess if
you were on the receiving end of that if
you had clients that basically took the
returns that you prepared and went out
for a second opinion uh is that
something that uh would you'd find
upsetting or you'd say you know I think
that that's a reasonable thing for them
to do both right like I think it's
reasonable for them to do it and at the
same time it's like ah come on I've been
good to you you know yeah um but I don't
feel like all accountants have that
confidence in their that they've been
good to their clients yeah uh but we
have had clients do that and a lot of
times they send us an email saying I
just want to let you know I got a second
opinion and I just wanted to thank you
yeah like thank you for doing a good job
because this other guy actually was
confused with some of the line items
like what's this strategy like what is
this you know and so I'm I'm sure our
clients have taught other accountants
the Augusta rule many times because it's
one of the easiest ones that we start
with like this if you're a business
owner it's such a blatantly good tax
strategy but other accounts I don't know
why they don't know it yeah or if they
know it they convinced themselves that
it it's applied to some other tax code
um but I no we've had that I in fact I
even had one guy one year he literally
we prepared his return and then he did
his return on Turbo Tax just to see if
he was going to get a deal with us uh or
like save money and you know I'm happy
to announce that we did in fact save him
more money than him doing himself on
Turbo Tax but yeah they yeah I it's
reasonable for them to do it yeah and
and I have to imagine Tero taxes be very
careful because there' be some
significant liability right so they have
to really error on the side of uh you
know being conservative yeah and it's a
software and now I know that they have
this the new things where you can talk
to a human and whatever and they can
review your return but the software
itself they're just asking you what's
your expense in this category right how
are you how do you know that as a
taxpayer who doesn't live in this world
where us weirdos read words and they
come up with weird accounting jargon
like you just you're never going to know
you need the accountant to say hey
here's this category this is what it
means do you think you have any
additional expenses that fit this and
that's a conversation that you can't
have with a piece of software um so yeah
that's that's one of those reasons why
that probably Turbo Tax would never work
I don't think for a business owner
another thing that comes to mind that I
think is a is a booming Trend right now
uh with you know Fiverr and you know all
the online we know contractor work sites
uh a lot of people are not business
owners per se where you know they they
literally have a business a team you
know a product uh you know whatever
service that they put out in the world
they're just a you know an army of one
they're graphic artist they're um you
know a copywriter they're um you know
whatever uh coder you know they program
they do uh you know they they they
develop websites it could be any number
thousands of things out there and I hire
these people all the
time so they are not W2
employees and they are not you know
business owners you know that you know
they're they're just one person but they
work for themselves so the the the
question I have is uh and this is
growing like Leaps and Bounds so the
question I have is number one should
they form an entity as compared to just
being you know a contractor and filing a
personal return uh and number two uh you
know are there a lot of tax advantages
for these people because they're they're
living or working in that way here's the
beauty of that question the tax code
basically identifies employees and
businesses mhm so if I get a $199 as an
independent
contractor I fall in the category of
businesses and so the same tax code that
applies to Apple and Microsoft and
Amazon applies to me as an independent
contractor even if you're not an entity
that that uh you know you're you're just
an independent self proprietor self
proor which is the worst way to be taxed
by the way so um I would to answer your
question about the entity it does depend
on their income level and is it like a
side Hobby
or is it a legit business let me give
you a scenario so let's say it's not a
side hobby it's it's how I work now I uh
I'm a contractor I'm a project manager
I've got probably only three clients you
know that I split my time up between you
know I maybe do 15 20 hours a week per
client um and uh I make a total of
$100,000 a year okay doing this should I
be a proprietor or should I uh should I
form an entity I would definitely
recommend in that scenario you be an S
corporation mhm so uh so basically you
you you form a corporation you file as
sub chapter S and then that's it so now
and then I want all the income to come
into that uh that es Corp yeah and it's
interesting a lot of people get confused
because they're like well I have an LLC
here not might not be surprised the
government can be pretty lazy sometimes
um when llc's came out the government
just said yeah we especially
specifically the IRS said we're not
going to figure out a new way that those
need to be taxed we're going to make you
tax it based on something that already
exists so an LLC isn't actually a taxing
entity it can be taxed as a sole
proprietor a partnership a corporation
and S corporation all of those are you
know LLC is just they don't exist
there's not a this is how an llc's tax
they make you choose right s
corporations you don't go to the state
and say I'd like to set up an S
corporation they ask you but you're
actually either setting up an LLC or an
incorporated business um the S
corporation status is the tax filing
status only and so just to be clear
because I sometimes people get confused
most of the time people have an LLC
taxed as an S
corporation um but for all intense
purposes it doesn't matter what the
three letters are at the end of the
business name if you've asked the IRS to
be taxed as an es Corp we just call it
an ES Corporation I see for Simplicity
but yeah in those scenarios the the
reason is is because of the way
self-employment tax works that 15.3% we
talked about if I'm a sole proprietor
and I'm making 100 grand um and if it's
just me chances are I have really good
margin MH uh you know I I might have 80$
50,000 to $80,000 of taxable income on
that mhm as a proprietor I get to pay
15.3% additional tax wow on that you
know 50 to 80,000 with an S
corporation uh that's not the case I do
have to follow compliance and give
myself a W2 from my S corporation but
that W2 doesn't have to be 100% of my
income so basically let's say that uh
let's do the scenario so let's say it's
$100,000 of of total revenue uh let's
say 20% uh you know expenses so 80 I'm
makinging
$80,000 and I'd say okay so I'm going to
maybe go on payroll for 40,000 of that
and pay the self-employment tax and then
on the other 40,000 it's going to pass
through so I don't pay that extra 15%
which is substantial that's right and
now of course it begs a question what is
the test for determining how much
payroll I have to take well in the tax
code um not very clear they Ed the word
reasonable compens compens ation that's
it there's no magic formula they just
say it needs to be reasonable well if
you have a conservative accountant what
they deem reasonable might be different
than an accountant who I don't want to
use the word
aggressive uh if you have an accountant
who understands the tax code and what
you're able to do they're probably going
to come up with a much smaller number
than what the super conservative
accountant is going to come up with well
I'm I'm told I should be maxing it out
at 130,000
yeah that's that's crazy that's crazy
that's crazy yeah in other words that's
being overly conservative you will never
make that payroll tax back on your
Social Security benefits when you get
older and it's not reasonable yeah there
are factors that have to be considered
and so it is definitely a specific
scenario that each person looks at
because how much like are you out is
that person Outsourcing any of the work
that generates Revenue do they have any
team members how many team members do
they have how many hours a week are they
actually spending in the business uh all
of those are factors that you have to
look into to determine is this
reasonable right and and sometimes like
well what could I pay somebody to do
this exact work for me not that I think
they're going to be as good as me the
tax code is neutral to that point it's
just if I need someone to physically go
through the motions I go through what
could I pay that person if that's less
than 130 Grand then that's the smaller
number well I guess you know if you're
looking at the contractor who's the solo
preneur if you will uh but if you're
looking at you know say somebody's
making a large amount of income and
that's really they're saying well you
got to max out at you know uh you know
if you're making let's say a million
dollars a year um you know should you
still max out the you know the 130 or
should you take less and I guess it
depends on it totally depend what would
it cost me to replace myself etc etc etc
yeah yeah it totally depends I but I
definitely wouldn't make a blanket
statement hey if you have if you have a
million dollars then go ahead and max
out your W2 for the Social Security tax
like uh I would never make that blanket
Statum because even if you can even if
$100,000 is the correct amount you still
saved 15% on 30 grand isn't it insane
how much efforts got going into just
figuring out
taxes right shouldn't it be simplified I
know if only I people ask that all the
time there was a couple a few election
Cycles ago one guy was running on the
platform he was going to just have a
flat tax
I and people get excited about that and
I love the idea that how simple life
would be if we all had a flat tax but
would that put you out of a job um it
wouldn't for me because we can we
consult with clients on cash flow and
other things so okay I'd be happy to
adapt I mean right now I feel like I'm
I'm the protector of people against the
IRS bully um and if that went away great
I'll find passion somewhere else and so
with this flat tax the problem with that
is that you have
politicians and what we might vote in as
a flat tax at 12% or 15% whatever it may
be they're always going to want to
figure out how to get votes and then
they're going to start saying you know
what I'm gonna I'm going to change the
tax this way really the tax code is
complicated because of all the platforms
politicians run on and they have to give
tax benefits to the people the groups of
people they're trying to get to vote for
them uh a flat tax would never work just
because of the corruption that exists
with politicians and always going to
want more it's like we got the we got
the whole world to sign off on the 10%
perfect well guess what we now have
control to raise it to 11 and 12 where
do they stop they're always going to
want their entitlement programs because
that helps their voter base and so I
yeah it would just never work in
practice I I always said I think the tax
system is more about controlling
Behavior than it is about collecting
Revenue because they can collect Revenue
in much easier ways much easier ways
yeah it really is I mean if you think
spend a lot less money yeah about
Obamacare uh he could not get it passed
as a law mhm and so he enforced it as a
tax yeah because the tax rules allowed
him to enforce it but they didn't want
to call it a tax right but enforces
behavior and and I think that's
ultimately what it is oh we want people
to own houses we'll give a break on
mortgages you know we want so consumer
Behavior can be manipulated through tax
incentive yeah one tax strategy we use a
lot especially with tax reform now is
the vehicles larger than 6,000 pounds
mhm how in the world like why is it
6,000 that you get a better tax break if
you buy a car that is like you know
guzzles gas more versus the other cars
that don't you oh you get a tax break
for over 6,000 if it's over 6,000 PBS
with now tax reform you can effectively
take the full cost of that vehicle in
the year you buy it where in years past
it's limited you don't even get the full
price and it's taking over 5 years are
are they considering those commercial
vehicles or something which is why
they're trying to help but they are but
they also provide a list of but five but
5,999 lbs no good no good exactly so
I'll fill my tank hopefully and yeah
I'll put you know cinder blocks and sand
and rocks in my in my car to get it to I
this stuff is ridiculous like how do
they come up with that number I don't
know because I'm there must be some
Behavior or maybe a car manufacturer who
paid money to a lobbyist and said hey
can you try to push this through that I
mean most of the tax code is that I'll
get an armor plated vehicle now I
remember when I was in college um the
the professor we studied a section he's
like guys remember this as the Microsoft
section they're the ones who got this
tax code implemented into our system
because they paid lobbyist and if you
read through it you're like yeah I can
see how this directly benefits Microsoft
because now that's a corporation trying
to influence consumer Behavior through
taxes yeah so you know and increase
their profitability at the same time I'd
love to tell you that you know GE I wish
we talk about this all day
I know and in some respects I do want
the information and understand it and
obviously you've given us a ton of
information but in the end it's really
about saying that I I I'm doing my
business at disservice if I'm really
learning too much about this I should
know enough to know how to find the
right expert to work with relative to
all this and uh you certainly have given
me and and our viewers a whole lot of
food for thought but in the end
I think one of the worst things an
individual can do who's trying to create
wealth or have a wealth breakthrough is
overpay on taxes that much I know yeah
and uh and I appreciate the fact that
you spend your your days every day uh
trying to prevent that from happening to
guys like me so uh so so thanks for
taking the time to sit down and have
this conversation thank you to see the
next episode in the wealth breakthrough
series check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there as a
franchisor we want to go into businesses
where we can make money as a franchise
or but we want the franchisees to be
able to do well